Mo-Mo-Mo-Monka-W
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Easy.
So, gucken ob Windows das wieder gecheckt hat.
Jawoll, weiß man nie so genau.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Handy aufladen.
wo anstöpseln
ich habe jetzt nämlich die kabel zum handy laden habe ich nicht mehr am
schreibtisch die habe ich jetzt hier so ungefähr das ist eineinhalb meter oder
so weg. Die Handys liegen auf dem Schrank, weil ich wäre immer teilweise hart gesitetrackt,
wenn mein Handy auf dem Schreibtisch liegt. Dann mache ich da immer zwischendurch Twitter auf oder
irgendwie oder ich kriege irgendwo irgendeine Push-Notification, gucke danach und mache dann
Twitter oder Reddit auf. Wir haben doch schon einen Dogploy Stream gemacht. Aber wir müssen
das eh noch einrichten, wenn wir das NAS fertig einrichten. Also das kommt eh noch auf uns zu.
Da muss ich wieder aufpassen, dass ich nicht wieder zig IPs leake.
So und jetzt muss ich mal kurz noch mein Headset entknoten.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wie sich das immer die ganze Zeit verknoten kann, weil ich mache
eigentlich mit dem Headset nichts, außer es aufsetzen,
auf den Schreibtisch legen, aufsetzen, aufsetzen, aber in irgendeiner
Art und Weise schafft es das Headset,
sich innerhalb von
zwei Wochen oder so, so zu verknoten,
dass ich noch die halbe
Kabellänge oder so übrig habe.
Gestern Radfahren,
äh, ne, vorgestern
und vorvorgestern und davor.
Gestern, gestern habe ich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe es, ich habe es noch, Tag davor
ging gar nichts, weil ich habe es noch so in den Beinen
gemerkt, da habe ich gesagt, ich mache jetzt mal einen Tag Pause.
ach so chat moment jetzt
wir haben jetzt ja hier die geschichte anstatt die linux vm ok moment da muss
ich mal kurz gucken übrigens ist richtig dumm leichtes linux vm genannt habe ich
überhaupt nicht die Linux vor allem. Linux mini PC. Okay, so dann gucken wir. Was? Okay,
Run in normal Mode. Was auch immer es für Schmerzen hat, keine Ahnung. Was hältst du
von Battlefield 7.
Als Battlefield 6, oder?
Noch gar nichts.
Weil ich es nicht gespielt habe.
Ne, ich habe es gekauft,
aber ich habe es noch nie gespielt.
Okay, okay. Und jetzt mal schauen,
ob ich das hier alles richtig
angeschlossen habe noch.
Schauen wir mal.
Und ich muss glaube ich ins Bios die Bootreihenfolge umstellen.
Chat, es sollte jetzt eigentlich was machen.
Aber es macht nichts.
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt.
Auch einfach ein bisschen bis zum Start.
So, wir wollen von der Samsung, ne warte mal, von der Samsung SSD mal starten, genau.
Ja dann, dann kannst du ja irgendwie irgendeinen Unterschlupf bauen für die Katz RF Programmer.
Und dann
Wenn die
Wenn die draußen rummacht, danach
Kannst du kastrieren lassen
So, ich glaube jetzt
Ah, da sind wir
Da sind wir
Excellent
Okay, zeig mal her, ob es jetzt
Gehört dir doch nicht
Die Frage ist, ob die
Dann lass doch mal Chip auslesen
Guck mal, ob dir überhaupt jemand gehört
Ha, Funst
Oh ne, Moment, Moment, Moment
Ah ja, ich weiß, was das Problem ist
Das buggt ja, hab ich ja ganz vergessen
So richtig perfekt
Ist das Setup noch nicht
Weil
Das muss hier auf
So
Äh, fail to connect
Aber nicht, das ist überhaupt nicht fail to connect
Siehste
Das ügt
Ich fail to connect
Okay, das muss ich irgendwie noch ein bisschen automatisieren
Dieses Setup
Ey, Alter, ich flipp aus
Warum ist dieser hässliche Mauszeiger jetzt wieder da?
Das letzte Mal haben wir das doch gefixt
Ich dreh durch
Dieser Mauszeiger, Mann
Das letzte Mal war der doch weg
Warum ist der wieder da?
Okay, okay, Leute
Deskflow, stopp
Deskflow, start
Ah, jetzt ist er weg
Ah, man darf das nicht Fullscreen machen
Das andere, okay
Jetzt, okay, beste, beste
Ja, es gibt Sachen, die
Muss man nicht wirklich verstehen
So, dann machen wir jetzt hier mal auf
By the way, warum
Warum genau habe ich jetzt eigentlich die Kiste hier gestartet?
Weiß ich nicht genau
Aber wir müssen jetzt hier, wupp, Lords
Pop-Out-Chat aufmachen.
Haben wir denn hier überhaupt... Ja, hier haben wir
FFZ und alles schon installiert. Sehr gut.
You can speech synthesis
because speech dispatcher
library...
Als würde ich
das wollen. Don't show again.
Geh weg.
Kann man
die Desktop-Icons... Oben links
eigentlich... Das da? Ach ne, du meinst
das hier? Du meinst diese Anzeige
auf welchem Desktop man ist?
ja, kann man
irgendwie, ich hab vergessen wie es geht
ähm
das ging
jaja
ich hab aber
keine Ahnung mehr wie
aber das ging
Ich weiß nicht
Oh ne
Da ist die Maus wieder
Maus, hau ab
Warum ist die hässliche Maus wieder da
Das macht mich fertig
Jetzt sind wir da weg
Okay
Äh, warte mal, doch, doch, das ging eben
Man konnte verschiedene Rows anzeigen lassen
Boah, hier, irgendwie
Virtual Desktops
Genau, und da konnte man jetzt sagen
Two Rows
Guck mal, dann ist es kleiner
Dann hat man das hier alles untereinander, siehste
Wo man gerade ist
Das geht aber, das gefällt mir nicht
Deswegen mache ich das wieder aus
Was ich noch nicht ausprobiert habe, ist
ging das so?
Vielleicht kann man es hier auch irgendwie
irgendwie einstellen.
Okay, verschieben kann man es.
Also ganz ehrlich, das macht mich bei KDE,
verwirrt mich noch ein bisschen.
Ich checke noch nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
So, Show Panel Configuration.
So, jetzt kann ich den Kram
verschieben oder ich kann sagen
Configure.
Okay, da sind wir schon.
Kann man hier noch einstellen?
Okay, das finde ich tatsächlich
sogar noch besser, wenn noch die Zahlen draufstehen.
Desktop Name. Moment, die haben einen Namen.
Ne, Blödsinn.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Okay, das finde ich ganz gut zu sehen.
Nämlich ein bisschen an i3, wenn die da oben die Namen drinstehen haben.
Show Window Outlines.
Brauche ich nicht.
Irritiert mich eher.
Was soll das heißen?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Achso, weil man mehrere Monitore hat.
Okay, also anscheinend ist das
eines der KDE-Dinger,
wo man es nicht
super im Detail einstellen kann,
wie groß hier die Anzeige ist.
Aber mal im Ernst, so groß ist der Unterschied auch nicht. Bei i3 ist es vielleicht
zwei Drittel davon von der Größe, aber das ist schon okay. Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
kannst du eigentlich, ja wo kann ich einstellen?
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, das ist auch überhaupt nicht schlimm, wenn das hier ein bisschen mehr Platz braucht, zumindest für mich,
weil ich benutze die Taskleiste ja für nichts.
Brauche ich ja nicht.
Übrigens, das ist falsch, das muss auf Desktop. Oh, das habe ich noch gar nicht gemappt.
Chat-Gill.
More. Kann ich sagen?
Move to Desktop 1.
Okay. Das habe ich ja noch gar nicht
gemappt. Fenster
moven.
Ich will nicht die Größe der Taskleiste
einstellen. Ich will die Größe dieser
Virtual Desktop Dinger, wie breit das ist,
dieses Widget hier einstellen.
Größe von der Taskleiste
ist okay.
so ja guck aber ich brauchte ja sie kann ruhig ein bisschen größer sein ich habe
noch gar nicht fenster musen gemap so
exzellent
auch mal update machen und ich muss sagen wie ich habe ich habe kein pacman
update dings irgendwie so ging es
Wie machen eigentlich Anti-CLI-Noobs System-Updates unter CacheOS?
Da drüber? CacheOS Package Installer?
Max, was sagst du zu den World News?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, was da gerade in den News ist.
Muss aber ehrlich sagen, das meiste geht mir voll ins Hoh vorbei.
Okay, wie macht man offiziell in CacheOS Updates?
keine ahnung ich würde ich würde es halt weiter was terminal machen aber darüber
anscheinend schon mal nett die upgradeable ok refresh list eine upgradeable das halte ich
für gelogen wir sind oder art schädlings bei der im iran macht es boom ja interessiert mich nicht
abgräte okay das funktioniert und ich habe auch noch nicht gemerkt gemap fenster schließen okay
das muss man auch machen aber pacman aber so update ich wollte gerade sagen es hätte mich
sehr gewundert wenn es innerhalb von einer woche keine anstellung package updates gegeben hat doch
immer ist das nicht immer so ein terminal tool von cash ist keine ich war zu blöd zu finden
aber es macht doch nichts weil ich mache einfach package update so wie sie es gehört über sie leih
oder du meinst es gibt so ein extra terminal vielleicht gibt es irgendwie so wie update
oder sowas update was update cli ok google wir mal kessio s2 update auto update update
mal cash us update in a terminal okay das ist ein pacman rapper wahrscheinlich dann wenn man
ein Update eintippt.
Ja, probieren wir mal aus.
Können wir auch gleich gucken, was da gealiast ist.
Jetzt muss er erstmal Kernel Update machen.
Dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich rebooten.
Reboot recommended.
Ja.
Wir können es uns auch einfach sparen.
Okay, aber was muss man eigentlich im Update?
Ja, wie? Von wegen? Lull.
Im Update ein.
Kann ich überhaupt nicht.
Ah, das liegt daran, weil ich nicht Fisch habe.
Fisch hat das standardmäßig gesetzt.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Ist das ein Alias?
woher weiß ich woher weiß ich denn in fish was es ist no update
ich bin dazu blöd für mich ist mir zu high iq
update
Aha, excellent.
Update.
Was ist das für eine krasse Magic hier?
Function update minus minus wraps, das ist so eine Art Alias.
What the fuck?
Es ist im Prinzip das, was ich auch gerade von Hand eingetippt habe.
Was ist denn bei Arch Linux?
Sekunde, Chatge.
Arch Linux News.
Und was für News soll es da geben?
Ich meine, das letzte News ist vom 20.12.
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Was, wie, hä?
Du meinst, dass dann so Sachen sind wie...
Achso, ja, wir hatten ja letztens den Fehler,
dass G-Lip 2 broken war und deswegen CacheOS kaputt war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Art-Schildungs-Geschichte oder eine CacheOS-Geschichte ist,
aber ich glaube, es war eine Art-Schildungs-Geschichte.
Switchen wir mal hier rüber.
Wir haben den ganzen Grafiktreiber aus dem offiziellen Repo geschmissen und ins User
DL NVIDIA, ne?
Hab ich glaube ich auch gesehen gerade.
Hier.
Tja.
.NET Packages may require manual intervention.
Warum?
War die Intervention, war das nicht so eine Sniper in Modern Warfare 2?
Ganz random fällt mir das gerade so auf.
Das war so eine Bold Action Sniper
im Original
in Modern Warfare 2.
Wo sie immer trickshottet haben mit
Arch Update.
Hab ich noch nie benutzt.
Ist das Self Promotion?
ein update notifier and a player das ist so mit important pre post update
tasks absolut kein blassen schimmer was es überhaupt bedeuten soll
abdecken auf schiff
habe.
Sister Applet that assists you
is important. Aha.
Und was kann das so? Und warum sollte man das
benutzen? Weil
Automatic Checklist. Ja, das kriege ich also.
Check for News. Aha, okay.
Das ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt. Offer packages.
Okay.
Eigentlich gar nicht mal so blöd.
Brauche ich nicht ich hau einfach einmal die woche hier in den tag mein update rein und gut ist
Wo wir gerade dabei sind können wir doch mal gucken
Was auf github so trendet
Und leute was aufschreiben
So, wieder da.
Cache ist für Noobs.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Dann ist es bei mir richtig.
Ich bin in so vielen Bereichen
übelster Kack-Noob.
Das einzige,
womit ich mich ein bisschen auskenne, ist Linux.
Sonst habe ich keine Ahnung.
So, Trending Repositories
on GitHub today.
Dann schauen wir mal,
was da alles so trendet.
heute haben wir wieder mehr Projekte,
weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
sag mal, ist das Frontrendering
hübscher geworden im Vergleich zum letzten Mal?
Das Frontrendering
sieht nicht mehr so potthässlich aus.
Was ist mit meiner Maus los? Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Das Frontrendering sieht irgendwie
besser aus. Warum? Gab es Updates
und hat das Frontrendering verbessert?
Das sieht jetzt
tatsächlich relativ schön
an. Das könnte aber auch an KDE
liegen ich bin das von trendering gewöhnt von was weiß ich was x11 da als
standard von trendering macht keine ahnung also was was trendet denn wifi
das kann ich nicht aussprechen dense pose oder sowas turns wifi signals in
real time human pose exterminate was was anhand von wifi signalen will das
erkennen, ob noch jemand lebt oder was?
Oder wie? Oder what?
Okay, wipe coded.
Was?
Das check ich nicht.
Pause estimate.
Also sprich, der
weiß, wie man ungefähr dasteht.
Gerade, ob man steht oder sitzt oder sowas.
Okay, ich hab dich ja das letzte Mal gefragt, ob das Leadspeak ist, aber das war kein Leadspeak, ne?
Dann lese ich es jetzt mal anders vor.
W491H, POG-Subscription. Danke für den Sub.
Guck mal, der erkennt... Okay, man kann hier mit... Das ist ja irgendwie cool, oder?
Man kann mit WiFi, anhand von WiFi-Signalen erkennen, ob jemand steht oder sitzt zum Beispiel.
Ob er atmet.
Heartrate.
WTF?
Ob er da ist?
Und durch die waren das Ganze...
Ja, und wie würde man das machen?
Ich meine, da braucht man dann jetzt irgendeinen Raspberry Pi
mit einem WiFi-Stick oder sowas dran.
Weil mit irgendeinem bestehenden Access-Point,
den man da hat, wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es braucht direkten Zugriff
auf die Netzwerk...
das WiFi-Interface.
csi capable hardware required
ähm
unit csi capable hardware
esp32 s3
hab ich
ein esp32
mesh is recommended
also sprich
man soll sich
drei bis sechs
davon kaufen.
Aha.
Das ist in der Tat echt cooles Projekt.
Also ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung,
was ich da für ein
Anwendungsgebiet
irgendwie
sehen würde daheim.
Aber
ich finde,
das ist ein richtig cooles Projekt.
Ich meine, man könnte so Presence Detection
natürlich für Heimautomatisierung verwenden,
aber das kann man einfacher haben.
Da tut es ja meistens ein ganz normaler Bewegungssensor.
Das ist halt ein bisschen problematisch,
wenn die Leute dann sitzen,
vorm Fernseher oder so.
Aber selbst da gibt es ja mittlerweile
Presence Detection Sensoren,
die das auch können.
Vielleicht machen die das ja auch so irgendwie unter der Haube.
Aber das ist ein cooles Projekt.
Würde mich interessieren, wie viel davon
Vibe-Coded ist und wie viel
nicht. Rustport.
Ganz wichtig. Ganz wichtig.
Leute.
Blazingly fast.
Okay, es ist Python und jetzt wird es zu Rust geportet.
Der Rustport ist aber noch nicht so richtig fortgeschritten.
Oh doch.
Massive.
Das ist alles Vibe-Coded, oder? Wollen wir wetten?
Der Raspot ist im Wolle das ist komplett weib coded
Der Raspot das ursprüngliche ding ist wahrscheinlich halbwegs von menschenhand und klopft
Entstanden und jetzt hat er gesagt porte mir dieses Python Projekt nach Rast
Aber leute die die dort und die haben doch
quasi
echte medizinische Geräte dran die Herzschlag und so feststellen
Scheitert auch, wenn du viele andere Wifas in der Umgebung hast
Oder meinst du, dass sie nicht umgekippt sind?
Ja, tatsächlich
Die Idee finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht
Generell
Ähm
Krankenhaus mäßig
Du hast ja Leute, die liegen nicht den ganzen Tag angeschlossen
Im Bett rum
Dass man da irgendwie was überwachen könnte
Ja, genau, dass man da irgendwas überwachen könnte
Dass da nicht einer umgekippt ist auf dem Klo oder so
das ist eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich das ja das stimmt auch aber die die sache
mit du könntest zum beispiel checken dass eine auf dem klo nicht umgekippt
ist oder so das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht das ist eigentlich ganz
gute ganz gute idee funktioniert nicht richtig hat es schlecht wenn es nicht
richtig funktionierten dann alarmiert wir es die leute rennen ins klo rein
der sitzt gerade da und drückt ist vielleicht auch schlecht
aber das ist 100 pro jahre abgeholt ja und ich sehe den anwendungszweck ja ja
Ja, müssen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen zuverlässiger machen, das Ganze.
Ja, also generell muss man sagen, also ich habe ja auch so eine Garmin-Uhr.
Forerunner 255S, glaube ich, ist das.
Und die stört eigentlich überhaupt nicht wenn man die an hat und die trackt auch ziemlich gut aber ich ziehe die in letzter zeit nicht an
Es stresst mich wenn ich mich dann ganzen tag kontrolliere mit
Mit mit ruhe puls und gedöns und schlaf und alles ich ziehe es eigentlich gar nicht machen
Moin Max gibt es gründe weshalb du unregelmäßig bei youtube bist bin stiller zuschauer seit black ops 1 hoffe dass du ich mach weiter ich
mach weiter also es hat hat
zwei Gründe.
Das erste ist, ich hatte wenig Bock.
Das hat gar keinen speziellen Grund gehabt,
aber ich hab wenig Bock
gehabt, ja.
Und das zweite ist,
dass ich aus
komplett, oh, was ist das denn alles?
WTF? Seit wann gibt's hier so
30 Milliarden Dinger?
Und das andere ist,
das hab ich ja schon mal im Stream erzählt, da will ich mich
jetzt gar nicht so sehr drüber auslassen,
Ähm, das andere ist, dass ich seit ungefähr einem Jahr oder so aus komplett dämlichen, hirnverbrannten Gründen eine Angststörung hab.
Und Probleme hab mich da zu konzentrieren und alles.
Und mir über viel Zeug Gedanken mach und ich einfach nicht so in diesen YouTube-Video-Flow wieder reinfinde.
Aber ich kann euch zumindest eins sagen
Weil ich das ja schon mal vor ein paar Monaten erzählt habe
Es ist besser
Naja, es ist besser
Ich hatte meine letzte Therapiestunde
Am 1. Dezember
Das ist jetzt quasi
Ja, 4 Monate
Ne, 3 Monate
Sagen wir mal
Also ganzen Dezember
Ganzen Januar
Ganzen Februar
3 Monate
Seit drei Monaten ist das eigentlich ganz okay.
Ich habe so die letzten 1-2 Wochen, das ist wieder ein bisschen schlechter,
aber das hat mir auch jeder gesagt schon, dass das immer so ein bisschen in Wellen verläuft
und es halt lange dauert, bis es komplett wieder weg ist.
Du meinst Psychologie, oder?
Ja, ja, ey, es ist komplett...
Ne, ich meine, die Gründe sind komplett dämlich, ja?
Ich weiß ja mittlerweile auch, warum ich das hab.
Und der Auslöser ist richtig hängen geblieben, Alter.
Der ist wirklich richtig massive hängen geblieben.
Macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Aber man steckt da halt nicht drinnen, ja.
So.
So, was trinken.
Hast du eine neue Linux-VM?
Haha.
Linux-VM.
Alter! Jetzt ist die Maus wieder da.
Ich flipp aus.
Ist ja schrecklich.
MonkaW.
Ist NAS4 schon da?
Ich habe kein NAS4 bestellt.
Das ist keine Linux-VM.
Guck mal.
Und ja, ich weiß, Fast Fetch.
Deswegen ist Neo Fetch bei mir ein Alias auf Fast Fetch.
Das ist keine Linux-VM mehr.
Guck mal.
Das ist ein echter Linux-Mini-PC.
Wie hast du das Problem mit Deskflow und dem Cursor eigentlich gelöst?
Das habe ich folgendermaßen gelöst.
Man muss...
Man muss Deskflow auf dem Desktop öffnen,
wo man dann
OBS in Fullscreen
macht
und wenn ich dann rüber switche
geht der Cursor weg
ich hab richtig krass
Views gehabt in letzter Zeit
wo ich Videos gemacht habe.
Das war eigentlich richtig.
Die Views waren, ich will nicht sagen so hoch wie nieder,
das stimmt nicht, ja, aber echt
nicht schlecht. Guck mal hier.
Die Views, bevor ich dann
keinen Bock mehr hatte und dann, ja, später
dann meine Probleme, die waren richtig gut.
Guck mal hier. 320k
einfach auf das Fritzbox-Video.
40k hier drauf.
36k, 54k,
87, 83k
86k
53 hier
Also die Views sind wirklich gut
163k
Also da kannst du
Da kannst du dich echt nett beschweren, ja
Man darf nicht vergessen, YouTube hat sich ja weiterentwickelt
YouTube ist ja nicht mehr wie
2011 oder so
Wo wenn du Call of Duty Videos guckst, weil du drei Channels zur Auswahl hattest
Oder sowas
Kennst mich nur von Twitch, finde ich auch cool
dass es leute gibt die mich noch von fit ist freut mich freut mich also die views waren richtig gut
fällt euch auf dass youtube der meinung ist es muss meine videotitel für mich übersetzen
moment haben wir denn jetzt überhaupt moment moment moment wenn er videotitel übersetzt ist
Haben die mich dann habe ich dann auch so ein englisches englische Tonspur Leute hier
Ne
Englische Tonspur habe ich nicht nur der Titel ist Englisch ja YouTube das hat es jetzt aber richtig gebracht
Max und willkommen meine
Ja ich habe ein bisschen Subscriber gedroppt ja weil ich halt jetzt einfach zwei Jahre inaktiv war kein Wunder
Ja gut was ist das eigentlich für ein hässliches ding kann sich das mal verpissen
Ja die übers auf reddit ist es auch schlimm ich habe hier keine audio spur
Wie höre ich mich eigentlich an in premium feature dreifach wie höre ich mich eigentlich alle zweifach
Schnell höre ich mich an
Die Maus-Netzwerkkarte 4 reloaded.
Netzwerkkarte 4?
Leute, Netzwerkkarte!
Netzwerkkarte! Ich muss euch was sagen,
aber ich mach das nass an.
Erinnert mich dran, falls ich's wieder
nicht checke.
Weil ich bin, gerade auch durch die Pillen,
ich bin ein bisschen
pepega im Kopf teilweise.
Erinnert mich dran, dass ich euch was auf dem Nass noch zeigen wollte.
Und zum Thema Netzwerkkarte 4, wir können demnächst tatsächlich noch was ausprobieren.
Ich habe nämlich noch eine Netzwerkkarte gefunden, eine 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte.
Ich habe noch eine alte, das ist ein wirklich altes Ding.
Ich habe noch eine Intel X520 oder so.
So eine, die ich mir eigentlich zum Testen nochmal bestellen wollte, weil ich weiß, dass die 3-Bar unter Linux ziemlich gut sind.
Das ist eine URL-Netzwerkkarte, die ist auch 10 Jahre alt oder so.
Habe ich noch eine gefunden.
Ja, die sieht auch mehr oder weniger...
Ja doch, die sieht ziemlich ähnlich aus zu dem hier, ehrlich gesagt sogar.
Hier, so eine habe ich noch.
Die wollte ich mal ausprobieren, ob die besser funktioniert als diese Mellanox-Karte.
Aber die Dinger sind halt steinalt und wahrscheinlich brauchen die auch viel zu viel Strom.
Also die lasse ich wahrscheinlich einfach im Schrank vergammeln, da wo sie die ganze Zeit lag.
Es könnte sogar sein, dass es ein Dualport ist.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine SFP-Plus-Karte.
Hier sieht man bestimmt auch, von wann die Dinger sind, oder?
Sieht man da nicht auch?
Wann die Dinger released wurden?
Release Date.
Die Dinger sind uralt.
2014.
Guck mal, die ist zwölf Jahre alt, die Netzwerkkarte.
2011 sogar.
Warte mal.
15 Jahre alte Netzwerkkarte.
Jawohl.
Die lasse ich, glaube ich, einfach im Schrank vergammeln.
da, wo sie die ganze Zeit schon rumgelegen hat.
Broadcom-Karte.
Nee, ich benutze meine Onboard-Netzwerkkarte
um Gutes.
Dank deinen Videos
hab ich damals vor 10 Jahren...
Fuck, bin ich alt. Ja, das fällt mir auch immer öfters.
Leute, stellt euch mal vor,
ich werde dieses Jahr
42.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Krass, oder?
Oldge
Massive Oldge
Warum gibt es eigentlich
WubOld nicht mehr?
Ah, gibt es
Ach, der RF-Programmer ist nicht subscribed
Deswegen
Verstehe
Ach komm, RF-Programmer
Weißt du was?
Du bist jeden Stream da
Als einer der ersten
Du bist immer so aktiv im Chat.
Komm.
Ich habe heute, ich habe gerade
meinen
Gönner-Sonntag.
So.
Excellent.
Ich habe, by the way,
wo wir gerade dabei sind,
ich habe noch 21,
sie über 21 offene Emote-Slots.
Ich müsste mal wirklich meinen,
wie sagt man so schön, Scheiß zusammenkriegen,
Arsch hochkriegen, mich ein bisschen
hier um mein Streaming-Setup wieder zu kümmern.
Weil ich streame ja in letzter Zeit sehr
regelmäßig wieder. Zwar unter der Woche nicht
so, dafür meistens
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag an drei Tagen
in vollem. Gestern ging es nicht, wie gesagt, mir ging es
wieder ein bisschen schlechter. Kann man nichts machen.
Ist halt so.
Und wir haben in letzter Zeit
auch wirklich viele coole Sachen wieder am Start
und auch
man merkt halt eindeutig,
wenn man regelmäßig streamt, hat man auch deutlich mehr Zuschauer.
Das freut mich richtig.
Übrigens, wenn man mich gefollowt hat und Bock drauf hat,
hier regelmäßig am Start,
kann ich das auch gerne followen.
Und das ist eigentlich sehr nice, deswegen müsste ich ja mal
meinen Scheiß zusammen kriegen und
mal Twitch wieder updaten.
So was Emotes angehen. Ich hab sogar animierte Emotes noch
frei und sowas.
Okay, eigentlich wollte ich aber das hier lesen.
Moin Max, dank deinen Videos habe ich damals angefangen und bin jetzt ähnlich wie du im Finanzsektor angestellt.
Aha, aber hättest du nicht vorher mal mit Veit und Dora...
Was Veit ist, weiß ich, was Dora ist, weiß ich.
Ja, Regulationsstelz ist halt so ein Ding.
Da kommst du nicht drum herum.
So eine Netzwerkkarte würdest du empfehlen?
Okay.
Server Shop Bayern.
Das ist ja mal ein geiler Name, Alter.
Exzellent.
Komm, da wählen wir jetzt auch alles aus.
Genau, Markus Söder approved.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Boah, Alter.
Ne, ne, ne.
So viel will ich dafür aber nicht ausgeben.
Ich glaub dir ja, dass die taugt, ja?
Aber 217 für eine uralte Netzwerkkarte will ich nicht ausgeben.
Kann ich lieber meine Onboard-Netzwerkkarte verwenden?
Wollte ich euch nicht...
Max 100.
Na, ganz ehrlich, Max 50 eigentlich für so alten Netzwerkkartenkrempel.
Aber das ist Qualität aus Bayern.
Aber wir können ja mal gucken.
Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass es die sogar
deutlich günstiger gibt, wenn man hier mal sucht.
Naja.
Kostet ja mehr als
meine Access Point neue.
Die Dinger sind schon übertrieben teuer.
Würde ich mir nie neu kaufen.
Ah, wo wir gerade beim...
Chat, warum ist die Maus wieder da?
Ich drehe hier noch am Rad.
monka w alle die maus jetzt ist weg irgendwas wollte ich euch ist es chat ich bin seitdem ich
die ganzen pillen scheiße bin ich echt ein bisschen vergesslich so ich wollte
ich auf dem nass noch was zeigen
aus schämen
noch etwas anderes aber wie dem auch sei bayern shop ach so ja ich wollte hier was gucken
ach nee jetzt weiß was ich gucken wollte ich wollte gucken ob ich
ob ich meine access points bei demnächst upgraden kann
ebay live?
what the f...
alter, was zum...
was ist das?
warum gibt es Livestreams auf ebay?
was?
äh
jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch
das macht
mein Gehirn gerade nicht mit
warum zum Teufel gibt es
Livestreams auf ebay?
ist das quasi so eine Dauerwerbesendung oder was?
Okay, ich mach das jetzt mal kurz auf.
Es interessiert mich jetzt einfach, was da abgeht.
Shop das Verkauf...
Ah, das ist so eine Art Auktion oder sowas, hä?
Nee, der unboxt.
Der unboxt Pokémon-Karten.
Okay, whatever, Alter.
eBay Live.
Also jetzt habe ich
Das ist doch eher ein KI-Bild, oder?
Jetzt habe ich auch schon alles gesehen, ey
Livestreams auf Ebay
Das ist quasi
Das ist quasi wirklich sowas wie Dauerwerbesendung
Ich wollte mal gucken
Ob ich meine Access Points upgraden kann
NR750
Für 350 Euro
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel
Also ich hab aktuell
Ein R710
Und ein R
510 glaube ich
So
Und das reicht mir voll und ganz aus
Aber so ein bisschen schnelleres WiFi
Würde ich auch nehmen
Das ist preislich gar nicht mal
Übel für diese Dinger
Die kosten ja tausend noch Apps, wenn sie neu sind.
Die Frage ist, ist das eine US-Version oder nicht?
Weil wenn es eine US-Version ist, dann kann man die in Deutschland nicht gescheit benutzen.
Und das Problem ist auch, dass man die nicht mehr umflaschen kann, weil die den Bug in der Firmware behoben haben.
Ist bei Ebay eigentlich das Gescamme so schlimm geworden wie bei Kleinanzeigen?
Also bis jetzt hatte ich bei Ebay noch nie Probleme.
Kleinanzeigen würde ich aus Prinzip nicht machen.
Ja, das wird wahrscheinlich auch hochgehen, ja.
Kleinanzeigen würde ich nicht machen.
Ich bin regelmäßiger
Enjoyer von
von was letzte Preis?
Und was man da alles liest, hat man schon keinen Bock auf Kleinanzeigen.
Außerdem bin ich gebannt von
eBay, es heißt ja nicht mal eBay.
Ich bin gebannt von Kleinanzeigen, wisst ihr das eigentlich?
Ich habe Kleinanzeigen nie benutzt, aber ich bin gebannt von Kleinanzeigen.
Und zwar wollte ich mir einen Account bei Kleinanzeigen erstellen, vor ein paar Jahren, schon eine Weile her.
Und dann kam irgendwie mit dieser E-Mail-Adresse ist es nicht möglich, einen Account zu erstellen.
Ich hatte nie einen Account, nie, nie.
und da kam dann irgendwie mit dieser E-Mail Adresse
ist es nicht möglich
ein Account zu erstellen oder
irgendwie sowas oder
recover jetzt dein Account oder irgendwie ganz merkwürdig
also wie gesagt ich hatte nie einen kleineren
Account was sein kann ist
dass ich mal einen
Registrierungs
Workflow
gestartet habe aber den nie abgeschlossen habe
ne ne ne ne ne keine
Self Hosted Mail Gmail Account
Da kamen die, war nicht möglich
Da hab ich an denen ihren Support geschrieben
Hab ich gesagt, die Leute, ich hatte nie einen Account
Warum kann ich mich nicht registrieren
Und dann haben die irgendwie sowas geschrieben wie
Bitte bleiben sie in Zukunft fern von unserem Marktplatz
Und da hab ich gesagt, wisst ihr was, fickt euch
Ich wollte den Kram hier nicht wirklich benutzen
Das war die, das war glaube ich so die
Frecheste Supportantwort, die ich je gelesen hab
Ja gut, dann halt nicht
Dann halt nicht, dann behalte ich mein Geld
will ich die scheiß plattform ähnlich benutzen
ganz so lange her ist es auch noch nicht
ja und dann kommen die leute was letzte prise und sowas
so das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich mal genau ob es ob es noch access points gibt so dass es
Es endet in 11 Stunden, null Gebote.
Okay, ist das...
Ich kann mir das...
Das ist die deutsche Version.
Ach ja, auf die Frage hin.
Warum?
Ähm...
Irgendjemand hat doch eben gefragt, warum...
Hier.
Warum wäre die US-Version nicht brauchbar?
Weil die regulatorischen Vorgaben
in Deutschland und wahrscheinlich in der EU, aber auf jeden Fall in Deutschland,
nicht genau mit dem übereinstimmen, wie das in den USA reguliert ist,
was Sendeleistung und so Zeug angeht.
Im Detail kann ich es dir aus dem Kopf auch nicht sagen.
Das heißt, streng genommen darfst du einen auf US eingestellten Access Point hier nicht betreiben.
Ob es jemals jemand merken würde?
Naja, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Genau, Frequenzbänder, das könnte tatsächlich sogar jemand merken.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob die Frequenzbänder da unterschiedlich sind.
Ich glaube, es sind in den USA ein paar mehr freigegeben.
Zumindest ist das streng genommen nicht legal hier zu betreiben.
Früher war das kein Problem.
Früher konntest du die US-Version bestellen und konntest die umflashen.
Man konnte die Firmware downcrayen bei den alten.
Da gab es ein Root-Exploit.
Nee, oder wie nennt man das? Ja, sowas.
Du konntest quasi root werden und konntest die WiFi-Hardware umstellen.
Und dann wieder die neue Version flashen.
Und es war gut.
Also man sieht, die Hardware ist exakt die gleiche.
Das ist eine reine, reine Config-Sache.
Aber nachdem man die Firma nicht mehr downgraden kann, kann man, glaube ich, hier auch nicht mehr die Region ändern.
Also sprich, was US ist, bleibt halt US.
Ich glaube, das liegt auch da dran, weil in den USA es irgendeine komische Regel gibt, Geräte, die Verschlüsselung anbieten, dürfen nicht exportiert werden und sowas in der Richtung.
Das macht dann auch noch Probleme.
Aber den, ohne Scheiß, Leute, den muss ich mal im Auge behalten.
Oder umgedreht gesagt, der hat aber keine so guten Bewertungen, der Dude hier, ne?
Mit Hermes aus Österreich versendet.
Ist mir doch scheißegal, woher der Dude versendet, Alter.
Das ist doch...
Was hat der Dude denn bitte schön für Probleme?
Da steht da 10 Euro Versand.
Ob er das jetzt aus Österreich, aus Deutschland, aus England, aus China verschickt,
solange es in anhängbarer Zeit da ist, juckt mich das doch nicht.
10 Euro sind 10 Euro, wenn das Ding ankommt, ohne dass es kaputt ist.
alles kein problem oder da sonst ist es okay also dass sowie w0 ist jetzt was
genau ist das das ist nicht das ist nicht ohne oder was ist was ist wie 0
jetzt für den access point es also ich glaube die dinger die anderen haben us
irgendwie im namen slicks danke schön für den sap
exzellente subscription kann nur sagen
Pog.
So.
Ansonsten haben wir vielleicht noch mehr.
Gucken wir einfach mal.
R750.
Ich weiß, ich bin schon wieder gesidetrackt.
Ja, weil das Zeug ist.
Wenn ihr das neu kauft, das könnt ihr euch...
Das ist krasses, teuerste
WiFi-Hardware ever.
Das Zeug.
Na gut.
Gibt auch andere Business-Dinger.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit haben die Cisco Access Points.
Die heißen aber ja nicht Cisco.
die heißen...
Ist das Meraki? Kann das sein?
Ist Meraki das
Cisco-WiFi-Gedöns?
Global Elite?
Pog, dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Nice.
Danke für den Sub.
Meraki ist es, ne?
Und ich glaube, die Dinger kosten im Endeffekt
auch so viel. Also die Enterprise
Wifi Sachen sind halt unsinnig teuer
Guck mal hier, was da Kram kommt
Und die neuen, ich glaub der neueste ist der
Äh
90, 70
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das
Die neuesten sind
Und die, guck mal
1732 Euro
Das ist schon ein krasser Preis, oder?
Für Access Points.
So, aber.
Genug gesidetrackt, Leute.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
SSH.
Wir gehen jetzt mal kurz aufs Nass drauf.
Äh.
Äh. Achso, das habe ich hier
gar nicht aus der neuen Kiste gemacht.
Yes.
So, jetzt passt mal auf.
IPerf 3 minus S.
Ja.
Terminal.
Wir machen jetzt mal 10 Gig Netzwerk Testing.
Äh, CD, Desktop, IPerf, IPerf.
Hm, passt mal auf.
Bär, äh, IPerf, ach so.
Passt mal auf.
Wir senden jetzt 10 Gig Netzwerk Traffic dahin und, und, und.
9,27
9,48
9,47
9,45
9,48
So, in umgedrehter Richtung
Ist schneller geworden, ne?
9,9, 9,2
Ist schneller geworden
So
Und, und
Ich kann euch noch was zeigen
Achso, bin auf dem falschen Desktop.
Lucky Luke,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog Subscriptions.
Kriegst du jetzt auch hier ein.
Danke für den Sub.
Was ich gemacht habe ist,
also ich habe mehrere Sachen gemacht.
Ich habe hier
alle möglichen Leute,
alle möglichen Sachen
ausprobiert,
an Netzwerktreibern
für die...
Achso, und ich kann euch noch was zeigen. Moment.
Du willst auch noch ein Nice? Okay, okay.
Chat für die ganzen Subscriber gibt's
jetzt nochmal hier ein paar Mal.
So.
Sag mal, für alle Subscriptions des Streams heute durch.
Moin, Markus.
So, jetzt muss ich mich verbinden auf die Kiste.
Jetzt kommt ja der Knackpunkt.
Übrigens, das ist falsch.
Ich muss mich ja als Max verbinden.
Zule Minus I.
Iperf.
Minus S.
53.
das jetzt eine VM und guckte mal hier
in der VM 8,5, 8,6
also minimal langsam
aber vollkommen okay
3,6, 3,6, 3, irgendwas
und jetzt
hinzu in die VM
9,1, 9,4
also man sieht es ist schnell
in der VM
als auch außerhalb
der VM
was sehr nice ist oder
finde ich äußerst
pogu.
Und
jetzt zeige ich euch mal kurz, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe hier alles
ausprobiert
an Treibern und sonstigem
Gedöns. So, was ich letztendlich
gemacht habe dafür.
Ich habe mir den
das ist der Treiber für
Netzwerkkarte, habe ich mir ausgecheckt mit
Config für DKMS.
DKMS ist so ein automatisches
Kernel-Modul-Bild.
Also sprich, jedes Mal, wenn ich
hier, guck mal mal,
gucken wir mal, ob es ein Kernel-Update gibt, zufällig.
Ne, wenn ich ein Kernel-Update mache, baut der automatische
Netzwerktreiber. Damit das übrigens
funktioniert, muss ich
den alten Netzwerktreiber
blacklisten.
Das ist der Netzwerkkartentreiber
aus dem Kernel.
Und das ist der Netzwerkkartentreiber
als eigenes
modul so also ich habe mir das hier runter runter geladen als mit mit dkms config dann habe ich den
neuesten treiber von realtec runtergeladen er liegt den habe ich hier runtergeladen und hier
rein kopiert den alten allerneuesten ja das ist der treiber von realtec dann bin ich hingegangen
in das make file nicht in das make file in das source make file und habe hier noch ein paar
configs gesetzt für die netzwerkkarte also das ist aber das ist wieder wirklich wieder frickel
frickel hoch 3 ja aber das schöne ist dass es jetzt wenigstens automatisch funktioniert so
und jetzt musste ich einstellen damit das ordentlich funktioniert hat das wirklich
schwarze magie ja dass das dass das also was ich gemacht habe ist hier das da
bleibt auf enable ich habe keine ahnung was es ist das war schon hat mich das
elbe keine ahnung was es ist keine ahnung was es ist keine ahnung was es
ist das hier habe ich von yes auf no gestellt aspm aspm ist irgendwas mit
power management power management für pc express device ist advanced blablub
power management ich weiß gar nicht was es was es steht
Active State Power Management.
Chat, das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Da muss ich, bevor wir das andere, jetzt muss ich da was zu sagen.
Chatke, Chatke, Chatke.
Wie wird sowas kontrolliert?
Das wird meistens gar nicht kontrolliert.
Das wird, das wird, ähm, es wird erst kontrolliert, wenn irgendwo Störungen auffallen.
Ansonsten eher Zufall.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Und unfundierter Meinung nach.
Ja.
Wollt ihr noch irgendwie...
Meraki
hört sich wie ein griechisches Restaurant an.
Ein bisschen, ja.
Malaka
Meraki.
Wollt ihr doch hier gerade noch irgendwas...
Hier, wer würde gewinnen?
Eins von den 1.700 Euro Dingern oder 12 Fritz Mesh Dinger?
Die Frage ist, Kyoto Käse, was du damit machen willst.
Wenn du einfach nur möglichst große...
Möglichst große Netz- oder nennen wir es mal WLAN-Abdeckung haben willst,
ja über möglichst großes gebiet dann gewinnen sehr wahrscheinlich 12 fritz box
mesch dinger wenn du einfach nur ein großes gebiet mit wlan versorgen willst
wie viele gleichzeitige kleinziehern aushalten sei mal dahingestellt aber
wenn es wenn es dir einfach nur darum geht dass du in deinem riesen in deiner
riesen villa in spanien im hintersten eck in deinem garten noch wlan hast dann
gewinnen wahrscheinlich die 12 Fritz
Mesh Dinger.
Wenn du allerdings Features
willst, wie zum Beispiel
PK...
Ne.
DPSK? Ne.
Wie heißt das Ding heute?
DPSK.
Doch, heißt DPSK.
Dann
kommst du mit
Der Fritzbox nicht so weit
DPSK
Damit kannst du zum Beispiel für jedes WLAN Gerät
Ein eigenes Passwort vergeben
Wir reden jetzt hier nicht von WPA Enterprise
Sondern die Geräte merken nichts davon
Was für IoT natürlich super ist
Prinzipiell würde ich sagen
Hast du wahrscheinlich auch bei
Äh hallo
Möchtest scrollen please
Was
Seht ihr das
Das mag nicht scrollen. Das hat keinen Bock, wenn es unten ist, zu scrollen.
Jetzt geht es wieder.
Mittlerweile kann das. Mittlerweile kann das Unify.
So.
Und die Dinger haben halt auch ein paar ganz coole Features, wo ich nicht weiß, ob die Fritzboxen sie auch haben. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, die konnten zum Beispiel die Empfangsqualität von einzelnen Geräten deutlich verbessern früher, diese Ruckus-Dinger.
weil die so so art so art dynamischer antennen oder sowas in der richtung
hatten also die konnten sich quasi so in die richtung ausrichten beamforming
weiß ich nicht ob das das gleiche ist ich kenne mich mit wlan sache nicht so
gut aus ausrichten auf die geräte die ein bisschen schlechteren empfang haben
Sinux, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Dankeschön.
So.
Also, wie sehr die rumfahren hier mit einem Kontrollauto und das dann merken, dass du ein US Access Point...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, ob die da großartig interessiert.
Übrigens, kennt ihr noch das Gerücht von früher, dass früher diese kleinen Transporter, die da rumstanden,
dass die angeblich feststellen, wer schwarz Fernsehen guckt?
Kennt dieses Gerücht noch jemand?
Das war früher voll verbreitet, so in den 90ern.
Wenn überall so ein kleiner Transporter rumstand, wo du halt jetzt nicht direkt erkannt hast, was der ist,
Da haben die Leute gesagt, ah, guck mal, der checkt hier irgendwie, wer gerade schwarz Fernsehen guckt.
Okay, das kennt ihr nicht mehr.
Das war in den 90ern voll verbreitete, so Urban Legend irgendwie.
Das haben sich ganz viele Leute erzählt, die haben das geglaubt.
Meine Mutter hat das damals auch erzählt und geglaubt.
Was natürlich kompletter Blödsinn ist.
War auch in Österreich so.
Was ja eigentlich kompletter Blödsinn ist.
Du kannst nicht feststellen, ob jemand einen Fernseher bei sich stehen hat, der das Signal, was eh da ist, empfängt.
Ja, das macht keinen Sinn.
Also ich will nicht sagen, dass es gar nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise möglich wäre zu gucken, zu checken, aber nicht so.
Nicht so.
Das ist genauso, was auch in Filmen immer gerne gemacht wird, ist GPS-Tracking.
Leute, in gefühlt jeder, ähm, ja, so wie, so Kimi-Sendung oder sowas, wird GPS getrackt. Das ist auch kompletter Blödsinn. GPS ist, du kannst nichts, keinen tracken per GPS. Das funktioniert nicht.
GPS ist passiv
Die GPS Signale sind da
Und ein GPS Gerät
Errechnet aus den Signalen
Den Standort
Dementsprechend kannst du nicht dieses Gerät tracken
Das ist kompletter Blödsinn
Was natürlich geht ist
Du kannst einen GPS Empfänger
Irgendwo dran packen
Der dann selbst wiederum
in irgendeiner Art und Weise einen Sender dabei hat,
der dir die GPS-Koordinaten zuschickt.
Das geht.
Aber dieses, wir tracken ihn über GPS,
ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Das kommt aber auch so in jedem Film irgendwie vor.
Wir tracken ihn jetzt bei GPS.
So.
Gut.
Dann gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet, würde ich sagen.
macht man das nicht mit Mobilfunkmasten
das funktioniert wiederum
da kannst du gucken wo das Gerät eingeloggt ist
und wenn du genug Masten hast
kannst du halbwegs gut berechnen
wo das Gerät ungefähr ist
das geht
Aber da sendet das Gerät ja auch was
Du siehst ja wo das Gerät eingeloggt ist
GPS ist rein passiv
Fürs Berechnen von Positionen
Also das
Die GPS Signale
Die gehen jetzt gerade durch euch durch
Ohne dass ihr es merkt
wie so vieles andere auch muss ich das mal überlegen von was man nichts merkt was gerade
alles durch ein durchgeht oder was sie was sie gerade 5g geht auch durch euch durch und und
noch noch viel schlimmer was sie sonst so alles ab kriegt zum beispiel zum beispiel wollte ich
kann zum beispiel licht licht kriegt ja auch ab strahlung die hintergrund
strahlung genau die kriegen alle ab überall im universum
neutrinos kriegst du extrem viele von der sonne ab
Milliarden Neutrinos, Alter, kriegst du ab.
Bekommt man auch Champ-Chat? Nur wenn du dran glaubst.
So.
Benutz doch Chat-Tour in der Twitch-Chat, im Browser ist eh Müll.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Sache.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Gibt es hier...
Ach so, ich war übrigens immer noch am Labern.
Kann das sein?
Ich war noch... Moment, Moment.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Ich war noch immer noch am Labern über meine Netzwerkgeschichte.
Also, damit das mit der Netzwerkkarte funktioniert hat.
Hier, also.
Das hier musste man auf No setzen.
Also sprich...
Active State Power Management.
Okay?
Das musste auf No gesetzt werden.
Dann habe ich
WakeOnLan ausgeschaltet
By the way, warum ist eigentlich mein Wim so blöd von der Farbe hier
WakeOnLan habe ich
Ausgeschaltet
PowerEfficient
Ethernet habe ich
Auch eingeschaltet, was auch immer es bringt
Kein Schimmer, man könnte das jetzt
Tatsächlich nochmal ausschalten und gucken
Ob es dann noch schneller wird
S0 Packet Magic
PoE habe ich ausgeschaltet
Das da habe ich eingeschaltet, deswegen eine Performance
geschichte das da habe ich ausgeschaltet ist auch in der performance geschichte vielleicht wird es damit da noch besser keine ahnung
Und den anderen kram habe ich glaube ich auf default gelassen hier noch komplett ausgeschaltet
wlan in wlan ausge hat jemand einen plan warum man wlan in wlan braucht wofür das gut ist
Ja, also so. Und in dieser Config ist die Netzwerkkarte tatsächlich richtig nice. 9,2 bis 9,5 auf dem Host und 8,8 oder was es war bis 9,4 in der VM. Also vollkommen fein, was das an Netzwerkperformance liefert jetzt, die Onboard-Netzwerkkarte.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe wirklich inständig, dass sie das demnächst mal alles in den Kernel integrieren, sodass man die Netzwerkkarte ordentlich auch benutzen kann mit dem im Kernel integrierten Netzwerkmodul und ich kein DKMS gedünst.
Ach, bei Brauch.
So, jetzt wollte ich noch hierzu irgendwas sagen.
benutzt auch chatarino ja das ist gut das gucken wir doch mal ich mache mir das
ding wieder aus muss nicht eingeschaltet bleiben
hier auch aus wo in q zum einen da wo du transparente netze fahren möchtest wo
beliebige wlan benötigt werden
du meinst quasi ich versuche das jetzt mal so zu zu übersetzen dass ich das
checke du meinst quasi wenn ich netzwerk infrastruktur bereitstelle und ich selbst
wie lands benutze und darüber aber meine kunden zum beispiel netzwerk machen und die wiederum
wie lands benutzen also dass ich quasi mein management wie lan und gedöns haben möchte
aber die davon nichts mitkriegen und da drinnen dann ihre eigenen wie lands benutzen können dann
macht man wlan in wlan kann man denn auch wlan in wlan in wlan machen kann man das beliebig nächsten
dann brauchst du doch ein custom köln wenn du die parametre ändern willst nee brauche ich nicht dass
ein kölner modul das reicht wenn ich beim kompilieren des kölner moduls das einstelle
Wenn die das in den Kernel integrieren,
nicht zwangsläufig.
Also man kann ja auch bei
Kernel
also im Kernel
Hardware-Treibern kann man ja auch Optionen mitgeben.
Hoffen wir mal, dass sie das machen.
Ja. So, Chatterino
wollte ich ja mal gucken hier.
Chatterino. Gibt's das hier
für 8 Linux, by the way?
GitHub
Chatterino.
Es gibt sogar 2 mittlerweile.
Moment, es gibt sogar 7. Jetzt blicke ich
nicht mehr durch. Warum gibt's da schon wieder
1000 verschiedene Dinger?
Seven TV hat
Chatterino 7 und das ist Fork von Chatterino
2.
Ja, wie jetzt?
7TV Name Paints, 7TV Personal, 7TV Animated, brauche ich alles nicht.
Building on Linux. Ich will das nicht bilden. Gibt es das nicht schon fertig?
In was ist Chatterino eigentlich programmiert?
C++? Ne, das benutze ich nicht.
Chat
Das wird nicht benutzt, Chat
Kein Chatterino
Wir müssen mit dem Chat hier im Browser klarkommen
Das einzige was mich abfuckt ist hier oben diese dumme Anzeige
Kann die nicht mal weggehen?
Das kann man doch bestimmt hier umstellen
Hier, FFZ
Jetzt wüsste wo
Appearance, Chat, Chat
Appearance
Wollen wir ein bisschen kleiner machen
Übrigens Wobbly Windows
Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich
Dass es zum ersten Mal im Leben ist
Dass ich Wobbly Windows
Seitdem ich diesen Mini-PC hab
Wobbly Windows mit 240 Hertz
Bei euch sieht es jetzt nicht so gut aus
Ihr habt nur 48 FPS im Stream, ja
Aber Wobbly Window mit 240 Hertz
Alter, es ist so weich
Stellt euch mal vor, es ist so weich, dieses Wobbly Windows
Dass ich den Text lesen kann
Ihr könnt den Text nicht lesen, ne
Das ist so weich mit 240 Hertz
Ich kann den Text hier drinnen lesen, ja
How large should text in chat be in pixels?
Das steht da und das kann ich lesen, während ich hier wackele
Das ist so, das ist so nice
Was soll ich mir angucken?
Chatty?
Du hast eh nur 12 FPS pro Auge.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das heißt, Chat hat 4 Augen,
dass sie auf 48 FPS kommen.
Twitch Chat written in Java.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht,
was ich da benutzen soll.
Chat, was ist jetzt lieber?
Ah, nee.
Aber Chat, mal ganz blöde Frage.
Warum benutze ich nicht einfach weiter den Chat im Browser?
Warum gucke ich überhaupt noch was anderem?
Macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, oder?
Ich musste ja doch nur, eigentlich was ich hier machen wollte,
wir können doch hier nur Appearance, Chat, Batches und den ganzen Krempel ausschalten.
Bitte Screenshots angucken.
Okay.
Ich bin zu blöd, diesen Kram hier auszublenden.
Keine Ahnung.
Man kann das hier mit FFZ garantiert ausblenden.
Also.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, was wir vergleichen.
Wir installieren jetzt Chatterino.
Was aber, witzigerweise.
Aha, das ist hier die
Chatterino-Bin.
Komm, git.
volle pulle
wir installieren jetzt beides
und gucken uns das an, ok?
so und dann hier unten
chatty
Java Chatty.
Drei.
Ah, wir müssen Java installieren.
Okay.
Ich will weder das eine noch das andere installieren.
Es muss kleiner 25 sein.
Ah.
Okay.
Ich dachte, man könnte 25...
Was ist das für ein Müll?
Gute Wahl 21.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Ich nehme einfach Default und gut ist...
Bam, bam, put it. No, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, massive password.
Chatty.
Oh, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Was?
Wie, will das mich verarschen?
Eben wollte es Java unter 25.
Jetzt will es Java über 21.
What?
Wie jetzt?
Ist das dumm?
Come on, guys.
Was passiert da oben eigentlich gerade?
Ah, C++-Kompilierungsstelz.
Okay.
Guck mal hier.
Die Kiste, die ist aber gerade auch ihr Geld wert, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
16 Kerne einfach ausgelastet.
Okay, 16 Fake-Kerne.
Es sind ja nur 8 mit Hyperthreading.
Aber es sieht trotzdem krass aus, oder?
Es slowt übrigens ganz schön
In der Zeit machen wir was, in der Zeit gucken wir
GitHub Trends, während das kompiliert
Wollte ich mir eh angucken
Also das haben wir uns angeguckt
War in der Tat recht interesting
Resting.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
Airy.
Self-hosted.
Your own croc companion.
Okay, AI.
A container of souls of waifu.
Äh.
Was genau?
Ja, ja, ja!
Was zum Teufel?
Was?
Die Kiste raucht.
Ja, volle CPU-Auslastung.
Aha.
AI stellt's für die Beeps.
Also mein Browser ist mega am Abkacken gerade.
Guck mal, sogar meine Maus kommt nicht mehr mit, ey.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Kiste ist voll am Abkacken gerade.
Vielleicht hätte ich hier wirklich nicht beides machen.
Sogar meine Maus freeze.
Seht ihr das?
Sogar die Maus freeze.
Oh.
Ups.
Arbeitsspeicher ist all.
Ups
Okay, okay, okay
Ich werde mal
Ich werde mal eins
Eins gleichzeitig machen, okay
Vielleicht war das
Vielleicht war das echt ein bisschen zu viel
Das Gute
Ach, ich muss übrigens noch mehr RAM kaufen, ne?
Weil die Kiste, die hat nur 8 GB aktuell
Guck hier
7 sind übrig jetzt
Nimm doch Chatterino Bin Package
Da hast du eigentlich recht
Egal, jetzt wird nochmal compiled
Jetzt funzt das bestimmt besser, wenn ich nur eine Sache gleichzeitig mache, ha?
Wobei, Alter, warum frisst das so krass viel Speicher?
WTF?
Ich muss meinen Browser zumachen.
Chat, ich muss den Browser zumachen, sonst kackt das Klavier ab.
Warum frisst... Was macht das denn da?
Warum brauchen das so viel RAM?
Das kompiliert einfach ein paar C++-Files.
Warum nur so wenig Swap?
Ich hab so viel Swap wie RAM.
Doch okay.
Und?
Wisst ihr was?
C++ Compile Times sind eh komplett affig.
Ich meine, Rust ist teilweise schon lahm.
Aber C++ Compile Times.
Das ist aber halt auch das Problem,
weil bei C++ dieser ganze
Header-File-Schiss,
Geschiss, was es da so gibt.
Das ist ja letztendlich nur ein
Reinkopy-Pasten von Source-Code
in andere Files.
Jetzt ist er voll.
Guck mal, jetzt der RAM ist voll.
Jetzt geht's richtig.
Ja, aber ich könnte das ja
noch nicht mal mit 16 GB richtig kompilieren.
Guckt euch das mal an.
WTF? Was ist das?
Was wird...
Alter!
Was machen die da?
Was machen die denn da?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Warum braucht das irgendwie 14 Gig oder so,
dass es überhaupt kompiliert?
Ja, so ein Twitch-Chat ist schon effigial.
Also wenn ich...
Chat, ich weiß warum.
Kann das sein, dass das ein Chrome,
Embedded Chrome irgendwie hat und den kompilieren will?
Aber das sieht nicht so aus aktuell.
War das nicht so?
Was denn?
Mit Chatterino brauchst du eh noch ein Plugin.
Für den Browser.
Ich will das ja auch nicht im Browser machen.
Gleich ist Swap voll.
Der war schon voll.
Nee, Leute, das gäbe ich mir jetzt nicht.
Da sitzen wir ja drei Stunden hier, bis der Shit kompiliert ist.
Was macht das denn da?
Das müsste eigentlich flutschen ohne Ende.
Auf der Kiste.
Na gut, das ist jetzt, weil er im Swap hängt.
Deswegen ist es lahm.
Wenn geswappt wird, ist immer lahm.
Chat, es wird echt Zeit.
Ja, ich breche das jetzt ab.
chatty wie sieht es mit chatty aus chatty ist ja bestelout chat angeblich chatty
das braucht hoffentlich nicht ganz so viel
er braucht was anderes den rahmen guck fertig kompiliert beim rahmen ist wieder leer dazu
was passiert hier jetzt chat seid ihr schon drin
Seid ihr schon eingeloggt auf der Kiste?
Der weiß, was da alles im Hintergrund gerade passiert
Moment, braucht das jetzt wieder so viel RAM?
Okay, ich möchte jetzt nur mal festhalten, ne
Sogar Java
Braucht
Deutlich weniger RAM
Ach, 10 Gig weniger RAM
als das C++ zu kompilieren.
So, Chatty.
Okay, schauen wir mal hier.
Jetzt muss ich natürlich den Browser wieder aufmachen.
Zack.
Da sind wir wieder, Chat.
So, und jetzt Chatty.
Chatty.
Okay, also.
Oh, nee.
Das ist noch ein Dings-UI.
Wie hieß das? Swing oder so, gell?
Das sieht ja aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend, Mann.
Flat Dark, ja, das geht vielleicht noch ganz gut.
Guck mal, der Krokronk.
Nee, lieber nicht.
Äh, ich will einfach nur an den Channel Wobblords.
You need to connect your Twitch account to use Chatty?
Ist doch IRC, oder?
Okay, Chat.
Läuft das jetzt hier im Hintergrund irgendwie?
Nee.
Okay.
Dann würde ich sagen...
Kann er tippen heute?
Läuft nicht.
Chatty.
Ey, heute kann ich echt nicht tippen, oder?
Ne, Java hieß das.
Java Chatty.
Chat, das war's.
Okay, Chatterino können wir noch ausprobieren
mit der Binary-Version.
Okay.
Ob das dann so viel besser ist?
Chatterino bin.
Also selbst
kompilieren ist ja anscheinend grad nicht.
Ne, wir müssen gar nichts
Wir können einfach den Chat im Browser verwenden
Der ist vollkommen fein
Das einzige nervige ist dieses Ding hier oben
Kann ich das nicht irgendwie löschen?
Bam, guck, weg ist es, zack
Beste Chat jetzt
Was spricht?
Und theoretisch, weil ich das nicht brauche, ne?
So
Guck mal
Jetzt haben wir sogar Fullscreen Chat
Also
Was will man mehr
Und wisst ihr was wir auch machen könnten
was auch voll klar geht
ähm
wir könnten auch
einfach
nicht der Servershop Bayern
wir könnten auch einfach sagen
okay das ist
vielleicht nicht so geil weil das kein Dark Theme
im Hintergrund hat
ne das ist nicht so geil
das ist wirklich nur für Chat Overlay
Das ist doch vollkommen top so hier.
So, okay.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob Chatterino da irgendwie mithalten kann.
Chatterino.
Click add to split.
Äh, okay.
Not logged in.
Jaja, okay.
Yes.
Wupp, Lords.
Okay, da sind wir, Chat.
Die Emotes gehen schon mal nicht.
Das suckt.
Wie schaltet man Emotes ein?
Äh, Plugins?
Emotes gehen?
Achso, nicht in der History.
Also heißt im Endeffekt
Probiert man den 7 TV Emote aus
Bei der Twitch TV
FFZ
7 TV Emote brauchen wir noch
17-E-Mode-Punst.
Okay, Chad.
Also, Chad, das wird so auch klar gehen.
Das Ding ist, das verschwendet ja noch mehr Platz.
Kann man das irgendwie fullscreenen oder so?
Das verschwendet ja noch mehr Platz.
als das im Browser.
Naja, nee.
Nee, nee, macht's nicht.
Aber mir wär's eigentlich ganz lieb, wenn man das...
Ja, das bringt ja nix.
Das find ich eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Das Frontrendering ist nicht so geil.
Das liegt aber bestimmt an Java.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das liegt an Java.
Ich wette mit euch, da ist irgendein Java-Gedöns am Start.
Guck, ihr seht irgendwie...
Teilweise sehen die Leute etwas...
Ach, das ist C++, stimmt.
Dann weiß ich nicht, was die machen.
Dann liegt es an Wayland.
Guck, das sieht jetzt teilweise etwas...
pixelig aus.
Aber noch durchaus erträglich.
Was kann man hier noch einschalten?
Nix. Man kann da eigentlich
nix wirklich großartig konfigurieren.
Und Areal.
Ja.
Eigentlich kein Unterschied.
Vielleicht sollte ich das hier mal auf 14 oder so einstellen.
Ne das ist egal, wenn ich das scrollen kann, juckt eh nicht.
Aber es sieht ganz okay aus.
Tabstyle, Compact.
Tablay out, left
Ah, ja das ist gut
Das ist gut, hier so
Weil da stört es überhaupt nicht
Ne, ne, ne, das ist gut, da stört es nicht
Ja, excellent
Chat, smooth scrolling
Ich hoffe, Chat schreibt mal
Ah, ne, okay, passt
jetzt bleibt es da oben stehen
ja
wenn ich quasi hier oben bin
und ihr was schreibt, dann scrollt es auch nicht runter
also auch ok
genau, sehr gut
Okay, das ist gar nicht übel.
Chat, sowas können wir tatsächlich hier irgendwie einfach immer mal auf dem vierten Desktop oder so mitlaufen lassen.
Wenn ich mir jetzt noch merken könnte, wo man diesen Kram hier...
Ah, das können wir jetzt einfach hier irgendwie mal mitlaufen lassen.
Dann brauche ich das hier nicht im Browser.
Dann einfach so zack hier, Chat, haben wir wieder auf.
Haben wir auch mehr Platz hier jetzt.
dieses ding am liebsten würde ich ehrlich gesagt komplett ausblenden
aber wen juckt da an der seite da an der seite stört es ja nicht wirklich
transition was transition ist aber du hast recht die sollten wir weg machen
wir haben doch noch mal neu installiert
Prozent Transition
wird schon der Stoff
um
Anni Machenzner
stellt man das ein oder
wird schon der Stoff switching an
ja die Alba das Recht ohne Anni Machen ist besser
okay jetzt kann endlich mal aus der Github Trends angucken
also hier für die bips cloud code trendet wundert mich nicht moment warum trendet das
genau ist es nicht das was diese kasse sicherheitslücke hatte vor ein paar jahren
oder vor einem jahr warum trennt er das auf einmal wieder so hart veritasium video daten
video dazu gemacht das ist doch schon uralt diese geschichte mit xz-rothills problemen
na gut es ist ja jetzt kein technik linux channel das ist ja eher so ein mainstream
science channel könnte man sagen das macht ja nichts wenn das da auch ein jahr später
ist weil 99,999 prozent der weltbevölkerung haben halt davon noch nichts gehört so
Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei Ei
ist aber richtig viel drin
max hast du das mit dem shopping mitbekommen ich weiß nicht ob du ob ich das gleiche meine wie du
ich habe mitgekriegt dass in shopping hat probleme mit irgendwie der us-regierung weil
weil die ihre AI-Plattform nicht freigeben wollen für irgendwelche Drohnenangriffe oder sowas.
Irgendwie so habe ich mitgekriegt am Rande.
Aber so genau habe ich das nicht verfolgt.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt hier was schreibe, ohne eingeloggt zu sein?
Ah, ich wollte gerade sagen, wie soll das funktionieren?
Da könnte man ja spammen ohne Ende, wenn man nicht eingeloggt sein muss.
dann schauen wir doch noch mal was trendet denn so in ok kommt weil blazing die fast
halb sprache development at the speed of light das ist so ein typisches ding das kann und das
projekt haben eine beschreibung wo keines weiß was es eigentlich macht space time db ja ok weiter
database and server combine into one.
Was?
But why?
Warum?
Instead of deploying a web or game server
sits between your clients and your database,
your clients can directly connect to a database
execute application logic in will ich das wirklich haben ja ist das wirklich was ich will
Okay, keine Ahnung, ob das...
Aber das scheint ja voll geil zu sein.
Internet gibt es das auch.
Naja.
Frontend in SQL.
Das klingt aber extrem
Painz Champ.
Wie baut man denn ein Frontend
in SQL?
das klingt auf jeden fall was richtig abartig ist
so gustrendet das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren bzw ich habe das sogar
ausprobiert das hat bei mir irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert mit tool usage seitdem
seitdem bin ich bei open code gelandet und das funktioniert echt ganz gut raster fest ja das
S3 Storage. Das ist S3 Storage, was jetzt immer mehr Zulauf bekommt, weil MinIO ja weg ist. Also
nicht weg, sondern irgendwie nicht mehr supported oder so. Das hatten wir schon mal. Das kommt mir
bekannt v
ah
Ich hab das blöde Gefühl, ich bin ja da sehr empfindlich was UI Frameworks angeht,
dass das nichts ist was mir gefallen wird.
Man muss ja mal ehrlich sagen Rust kann auch schon echt hässlich aussehen oder?
Ich mein WTF.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das bedeuten soll.
Also das hier checke ich, ja?
Das ist quasi this in Rust.
So, was...
Was ist
Underscore-Doppelpunkt
an der Stelle?
Was bedeutet das überhaupt?
ungenutzt ja aber das macht doch an der stelle überhaupt keinen sinn dass es
ungenutzt was ist denn genau ungenutzt window ist es ja anscheinend nicht
das bedeutet doppelpunkt das machst ja wenn du den typ explizit deklarieren willst ja also
Also das hier ist der Typ.
Da wäre der Variablen-Name.
Nee.
Das hier ist der Variablen-Name, oder?
Aber ey, what the f...
Ach, Windor ist der Typ.
Ach, so rum war das.
Wir sind ja in Rust.
Da ist es ja umgedreht.
Also, ah ja, okay.
Der zweite Parameter ist das da und das ist unbenut...
Okay, macht Sinn.
Macht Sinn, ja.
Es liest sich auch trotzdem nicht schön.
Das hier sieht wiederum ganz okay aus.
Guck mal, das sieht fast aus wie ein Vampir.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
So ein Vampir mit zwei Zähnen.
Hier, das sind die Zähne.
Das ist so das Gesicht vom Vampir.
und klick unbenutzt unbenutzt unbenutzt printlein klickt
ja komplett ob wir es was da passiert also weiß nicht versteht ist echt übelster karten
ja geht aber klar
sc cash ist sie ist sie cash like tool okay ich weiß nicht was sie cash ist also fällt
schon mal fällt schon mal raus bei mir guck mal ob seine gute erklärung für
gibt compiler rapper ende wollte compilation impossible schnellere kommt kommt heim
Compiler Cache
C++ geh weg. Z ist wieder am Start.
Warum man das braucht, verstehe ich auch nicht
Weil ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich
diese ganzen Git-UIs sehe, Leute
Ich verstehe nicht, was die Leute
daran mögen
Eines der wenigen Gründe für mich, den UI zu verwenden
in Git ist so ein History-Graph oder sowas
Weil es in der Command-Teile jetzt nicht so
dolle aussieht
Vielleicht noch für Diffs oder so
Aber ansonsten...
But...
Start.
Ansonsten keine Gui-Krams.
Command Line is the way.
80 Monate massive Subscriptions.
Dankeschön.
Excellent.
The Game.
402.
Wo ich gerade 402 lese,
ich werde dieses Jahr 42.
Kann ich mir selbst gar nicht vorstellen.
Richtig alter Sack mittlerweile.
Old Girl.
Ja, richtig Old Girl.
Lance.
Dann wird es Zeit für Frau und Kind.
Bin ich mit 42 für Kind nicht schon viel zu alt?
Okay, ich weiß, es gibt irgendwelche
Promis, die mit 72 noch Kinder kriegen, aber das muss ja nicht sein.
Als Typ nicht, okay ja stimmt.
Aber ich mag keine Kinder, Kinder sind übelst nervig.
F-Programmer, keck mich, Alter.
402, ja.
Das Stealth-Clown war das.
Kennt das noch irgendjemand?
Das war zu...
Zu MW3-DLC oder sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich hier bin.
Ich bin ein...
Genau.
Und ich habe gemerkt, als ich kämpfe, dass ich vor einem Clown stehe,
dass es so hoch sein sollte, dass man dort fahren muss.
Aber mein Kopf ist einfach da, wo der Clowns Kopf sein sollte.
Also benutze ich das als perfekte Hüfte.
Und so sind da die Sichtlinien, die durchlaufen und sie denken, es ist nur ein Clown, es ist okay.
Aber ich habe meinen Pistolenposten dort auf seiner Hand,
wie einfach die Leute wegzunehmen.
Und ich liebe das, weil es ein perfekter Moment war, als ob sie überhaupt nicht wissen, dass ich hier bin.
Ich bin ein steifes Clown.
Sie haben keine Ahnung, dass ich hier bin.
So dumm, Alter. Die haben damals schon Blödsinn gelabert.
Übrigens, wo ich gerade die Xbox 360 sehe, ist euch eigentlich klar,
dass die Xbox 360 nur 512 MB RAM hatte?
Der hat richtig viel Scheiße gelabert, ja.
Das Ding hatte nur 512 MB RAM.
Da sind so Sachen wie Gears of War drauf gelaufen, das alte MW2,
Battlefield 3
GTA 5 by the way
kam dafür raus
512 MB RAM
damals wurde nur optimized hier
und ich glaube 3 CPU Kerne
hatte die Xbox 360
das war für die damalige Zeit
richtig krass viel.
Als es rausgekommen ist.
GTA 5 kam für die
Ja!
Release von GTA 5 war auf der Xbox
360.
Da kann man sich vielleicht nicht mehr wirklich
dran erinnern, aber das war so.
Das lief mit 512 MB
RAM.
15 jahre her mit ganz 13 jahre
für die nächste generation die gewahr aber noch nicht raus an der stelle des release
war auf der xbox 360 was hat die switch an rahmen ich habe keine ahnung
mal gucken was die AI sagt
4 Gig
ah das wird Nintendo bestimmt jetzt zum Anlass
nehmen und sagen
das wird teurer weil RAM teurer wird
das muss mindestens
80 Euro teurer werden weil RAM teurer wird
achso und bei der Xbox 360 war es ja auch so
die Xbox 360 die hatte
ich glaube drei cpu aber die haben das sehr clever gemacht damals
triple core triple core power pc hat die 3,2 gigabyte das ding war für die damalige zeit
echt flott ja so und also für 2005 triple core 3,2 gig power pc als das ding war hatte richtig
rechnet. Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen,
die Xbox 360 war, glaube ich,
wenn ich es jetzt nicht ganz durcheinander bringe,
die langlebigste Konsolengeneration,
die es je gegeben hat.
Also die waren zum Release auch
richtig hart, die Dinger. Also richtig,
richtig brutal schnell.
Und ich glaube, die haben das
recht clever gemacht mit dem Triple
Core CPU. Zwei waren exklusiv
für Games und der dritte,
der konnte
für das UI benutzt werden.
Ja genau die Dinger sind damals abgekackt.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Äh.
Ähm.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Moment, ich muss erstmal vorspulen.
Erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Die Xbox in den Ofen?
So geil, Alter, was man damals gemacht hat.
Und wir haben den trockenen Plastik gegrifft.
200 für 2 Minuten.
Der hat es mit dem Plastik da halt reingeschoben.
People were saying they did it much longer.
Better people buy them on eBay.
Oder es ist ein Cheap Aid Video.
So I must let it cook too.
Games that might be in there.
Genau.
Broly is supposed to just do the motherboard.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
seit wann schiebt man das?
Ja, das ist ordentliche 2005-Qualität.
Es gab auch noch...
Es gab auch noch zwei weitere Fixes.
Der erste Fix war, die Xbox mit einem Handtuch zuzudecken und einzuschalten,
in der Hoffnung, die wird so heiß, dass sich das wieder zusammenlötet.
Und das zweite war diese Geschichte mit dem Föhn.
Was heißt ein Hairdryer oder so heißt das, oder?
Was heißt ein Föhn auf Englisch?
Hairdryer?
Dryer?
How to fix Red Ring of Death.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Also, mit dem Föhn, das ist quasi so Heißluft der Hausfrau.
Wenn man so ein ordentliches Heißluftding hat, dann ist das schon besser als ein Föhn.
Aber die Leute hatten halt nur einen Föhn.
Ja, guck jetzt wird heiß luftet.
Hier.
Irgendwo.
Ja.
Und dann geht's wieder.
Was ich bis heute nicht genau gecheckt habe,
viele Spiele auf der Xbox 360 waren so ein bisschen ausgewaschen graumäßig.
Ich habe das immer früher so auf Unreal 3 geschoben.
Es gab auch Spiele, die waren genau das Gegenteil.
Was ist das?
Erstes Video. Das ist der im Zoo, das erste Video auf YouTube, ne?
Genau.
Naja, gut.
Aber so war das.
Das war richtig, richtig
abgedrehtes Zeug damals.
Aber wie gesagt,
man darf nicht vergessen,
das Ding hatte nur
512 MB Speicher.
Hier, guckt.
bin ich blind wo steht es denn wie viel memory
jetzt seht ihr irgendwo
Es hat 512
Ja, hier steht es
Hat 512 MB Arbeitsspeicher
DDR3
Na, Chat, ob ich mal meine Xbox aufmachen soll
Den Grafikspeicher
Den Speicher auslöten soll
Naja gut, genug
Alles Xbox 360
Gedöns
Was mein erstes
YouTube Video war, das gibt es nicht mehr
Da hatte ich Musik drin
Das war ein Call of Duty 5
Video glaube ich
Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Also ich glaube, das erste Video, was man noch auf dem Channel sieht, ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr das erste Video.
Ja genau, ich glaube, da waren zwei noch davor.
da waren zwei stück glaube ich noch davor zwei oder drei sogar davor
einer das das das mail of honor
Guck mal!
Man hat sogar hier...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
habe ich hier hinten sogar...
Interessant.
Woher kommen denn die Kapitel?
Du meinst, ob ich das war mit dem Kapitel eingefügt?
Das war ich nicht mit dem Kapitel eingefügt.
Oder meinst du das Gameplay?
Das Gameplay war ich.
Natürlich. Eindeutig.
Der Informatikorps.
41-3 TDM.
Wie geht denn das überhaupt?
Das sind auch mehr oder weniger alle Kills von mir gemacht, oder?
Oh, guck mal.
Ich wurde geflamed.
Warte mal. Warte mal. Warte mal.
Wurde ich geflamed? Das muss ich mir anhören.
Malaka hat er gesagt
Das ist ein Grieche also
Jaggernaut
Ich mein, das war auch abfuck, ne?
Hier
Juggernord MP40.
Ich...
Es war schon witzig teilweise
früher.
Aktuell habe ich so überhaupt kein
Bock auf
Call of Duties mehr.
die letzten 2 überhaupt nicht mehr meins
ich habe nicht einmal 46 richtig spiel
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich werde ich auch super schlecht
ist ja schon Jahre her wo ich war ein bisschen
Petite kann man das ja gar nicht nennen
interessierter durch das zuletzt Schuter gespielt habe
ich bin wahrscheinlich jetzt richtig
richtig
Old dude, der alles
über, unter, aimt
und nix mehr trifft.
Das ist wie
Fahrradfahren. Ja, also
immer wenn ich mal wieder ein bisschen angefangen hab,
nach spätestens ein, zwei Tagen geht's dann
ganz gut.
Aber am Anfang wird das richtig,
komm an, re-aim, genau.
So, dann können wir uns mal angucken,
was wir uns auf YouTube zu Gemüte führen können.
Aber früher gab es noch kein Skill-Based Match.
Nein, gab es nicht. Das war viel besser.
Es gab Spiele,
die waren halt so kacke, da hast du nur auf den Sack
gekriegt und es gab Runden, da hast du Glück,
da hast du nur Loops und da hast du übelst alles
weggebashed.
Das war mir persönlich lieber.
technik keller hat ein technik keller haben wir da bei dem haben wir schon ewig nicht mehr
reingeguckt techniker kann kann sie alles klar ein mainboard von 1989 was uns vor spulen gucken
Laptops.
Pentium 3.
Ah, das waren auch die guten Thinkpads mit dem Nippel.
Wobei, haben die heute immer noch.
Windows XP, beste.
Ich hätte eigentlich mal die ganz, ganz olle.
Boah, ja.
Damals waren die Komponenten auf den Mainboards noch so fett, da konntest du selbst löten.
Chat, wer von euch weiß noch, was das hier für Slots sind?
ISA. Ja, richtig.
Ihr wisst, nee, es ist nicht AGP. ISA. Richtig. Ja.
Was das da unten ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Ist das so extra length ISA oder was ist das?
GPU, Isa.
Guck mal, hier kann man vielleicht sogar noch was dranlöten.
Das hier unten, ist das was?
Ist das der RAM?
Ist das hier der RAM?
Das ist die CPU auf jeden Fall.
Das erkennt man als einziges.
Das hier ist bestimmt der RAM, hä?
War schon irgendwie ganz cool, so alte Hardware.
Wobei ich sagen muss, so Hardware, das ist für mich auch Steinzeit, ja.
Das würde ich mir auch nicht zum...
Da habe ich jetzt keine besonders nostalgischen Gefühle bei.
Aber du konntest dann auch selbst dran rumlöten.
Was machst du denn jetzt damit,
außer zum Wertstoffhof zu bringen?
Äh, ja, ich gar nichts.
Er guckt sich das an für ein Video, würde ich sagen.
Und dann bringt er es zum Wertstoffhof.
Oder schmeißt es weg.
Weil mit so einem ganz ollen Zeug,
das hat für mich noch nicht mal, wie gesagt,
also für mich persönlich, ja,
nicht mal großartigen Nostalgiewert.
bei mir wird es beispielsweise anders aussehen wenn ich so eine alte kiste mit pentium 2 und
wu du 2 sli haben würde die würde ich tatsächlich benutzen für alle games von damals
Okay, da ist Naschzeug drin, auch gut.
Xbox-Laufwerke.
Ah, das ist die Original-Xbox.
Schau mal, was eine Voodoo 2 gerade kostet
Die Dinger sind übelst teuer
Die sind schon seit Jahren übelst teuer
Die Dinger sind schon, die Dinger sind, ja, die Dinger sind seit Jahren schon teuer as fuck.
Das ist fast schon Wertanlage, Voodoo 2 Grafikkarten.
By the way, irgendwie hatte ich in der Mitte, die Voodoo 2 hatte 12 MB, äh, 16 MB RAM und nicht 12.
Aber vielleicht liege ich da auch einfach falsch.
weil die haben alle 12 und da vielleicht verkauft ja vielleicht verkauft ja auch
sogar 12 das ist nur die erste brücke die erste brücke was im endeffekt hat idee kabel ist
dieser local bus das ist der mit dem langen slot das ist quasi was für grafikkarten damals
gewesen ist quasi der pc express 16 fach der damaligen zeit so es gibt kein sli mehr bei
amd weiß ich gar nicht ob die da irgendwas haben aber nvidia hat das hier abgeschafft seit der
30 30 90 30 90 waren glaube ich die letzten die das unterstützt haben
schon irgendwie cool die dinger gewesen vor allem das hier ist halt ich meine der kriegt
ja auch noch halt die kohle weil das halt mit original mit original packung und allem ist
original packung original cd das ist für die ganzen sammelstelle leute
also das ist das ist echt teuer 45 euro lieferung
die creative das war hier die die alle haben wollten damals
Kann man da vorspulen irgendwie?
Guck mal, was mit 12 MB Grafikspeicher alles lief, hä?
Das war damals absolutes High-End-Gaming.
Sieht besser aus als moderne Pokémon Switch Spiele.
Das stimmt.
Ja, das war schon was.
Also das ist was, das ist, äh,
sowas würde ich mir tatsächlich
aus Nostalgiegründen gönnen.
Ja.
also wenn es mir mal danach ist so ein pentium 2 system pentium 2450 nvidia tnt 1 plus wu du 2
sli mit zweit das das war so das absolute krasse high end system was man damals bauen
konnte weiß ich wie man weiß nicht wie viele rammern damals hatte 32 mb oder sowas
Mit 128 war es der Gangster.
Hatte man damals 128, ja?
So viel.
Warte mal.
P2 Maximum Ram.
Boah.
Der konnte bis zu 192?
Was?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das kann nicht sein.
Als ich eben 192 gelesen habe, habe ich gedacht MB.
Aber dann stand auf einmal GIG dahinter.
Typische Praxis.
128 bis 520.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nur 884 adressieren.
Ja, 128.
128 war damals eher so das Ding.
384 Maximum.
Ja und das witzige ist, jeder hat ja was anderes.
Also bei mir wäre es zum Beispiel so ein Pentium 2 mit Voodoo 2, SLE, TNT 1 und so drin.
Das würde bei mir so dieses Retro-Gefühl auslösen.
Bei anderen ist es ein C64 oder sowas.
Bei noch anderen muss es ein alter Atari sein
Oder ein 486er
Oder whatever
Für manche eine ist es heute die Xbox 360
Wobei ich sagen muss, an die Xbox 360
Habe ich auch eine heiße Erinnerung
Für mich ist es immer noch die beste Konsole
Ever
Also ich habe noch die Xbox 360 da
Ich war so doof und hab beim Umzug damals meine Wii und mein N64 weggeschmissen.
Super Nintendo hab ich noch. Was kostet ein N64 mittlerweile?
Auch nicht mehr ganz billig.
Aber eigentlich dumm, man sollte keine Konsolen wegschmeißen.
Wii U habe ich auch noch irgendwo rumliegen.
Erste Xbox hatte ich nie.
So, dann gucken wir mal, was wir uns auf YouTube anschauen können heute.
Aber hier passt alles durch.
Was geht eigentlich mit der Musik gerade ab?
Viel zu laut.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Bisschen leise.
Was kann man sich noch YouTube angucken oder was haben wir denn hier ohne blies
Home-Laptop der technik
50 kuba nettes cluster mittlerweile um kuba nettes cluster zu hausen die kuba nettes cluster hausen und kuba nettes cluster zu managen
Das muss jetzt das muss jetzt angucken das muss ich danke da kann ich wieder ein bisschen flame wie unsinnig das ganze daheim ist
Kannst du vor dem video noch mal kurz hier gucken
Wo denn? Was denn? Wie denn? Wo? Was? Wie?
Hey Max, achso hier.
Hey Max, du hast doch dieses N5R.
Ich bin auf der Suche nach einer Alternative für mein altes...
Ich hätte aber gerne ein OS, welches einfach Backup und Restore...
Guck mal, man kann das ja sogar anklicken.
Das finde ich in der Tat sehr nice.
Ich bin auf der Suche nach einer Alternative für mein altes Synology NAS.
Ich hätte aber gerne ein OS, welches einfach Backup und Restore ermöglicht. Optimal mit kleinzeitiger Verschlüsselung im Backup. Was nimmt man da heutzutage so?
Okay, ich würde schon mal nicht, also ganz ehrlich, ich finde weder bei Ugreen das Standard-OS von denen sonderlich toll, noch finde ich das Minis-Forum-OS toll.
Also das kannst du eh vergessen, was damit ausgeliefert wird.
einfache Backup und Restores.
Da fällt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt so nichts ein,
außer extra Geschichten.
Bei Synology ist halt das Schöne,
es ist alles dabei.
Ich habe Synology Backups noch nie verwendet,
aber ich denke, da ist auch was dabei für alle Plattformen.
Willst du, Moment, was willst du Backupen?
Willst du auf das NAS
Backupen oder willst du die Sachen,
die auf dem NAS sind, nochmal Backupen?
Also für Backups selbst, sowas wie Airclone
immer ganz nice.
Die Datenform nach selbst,
ich glaube,
also bei mir ist das so, ich mach das
super billig gerade. Ich mach einfach
ein Airsync nachts auf der externen Platte.
Fertig.
Die 7 OS hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen,
das haben wir uns letztens angeguckt.
Also Airclone ist glaube ich
ganz nice für so Offsite-Backups.
Und was auch noch relativ beliebt ist, Copia Backup oder so.
Das da.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich schon mal kurz ausprobiert, fand ich ganz gut.
Und ich glaube Airclone ist auch ganz gut, das habe ich aber noch nie ausprobiert.
Duplicate habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also die zwei Dinger sind glaube ich ganz nice.
Mehr weiß ich da jetzt aber auch nicht zu.
Borg-Backup finde ich ein bisschen zu umständlich für die meisten Leute.
Und der Windows-Support ist jetzt nicht so geil.
Wobei du willst ja kein Windows-Backup.
Resting ist glaube ich auch nicht schlecht, ja.
So, aber mehr weiß ich dazu jetzt auch nicht.
Woher weiß der, dass ich AdWoblos bin hier drin?
Ah, weil ich im Chat von Woblos bin.
Guck mal hier, Chaterino ist richtig High IQ, oder?
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Das ist nicht schlecht hier.
Das ist nicht übel.
Den Hintergrund könnte man noch ein bisschen dunkler machen, oder?
Falls das geht
Geht das? Background?
Äh, Moment, wo könnte das jetzt sein?
Hier, ah ne, es gibt nur Dark
Man kann den Background selbst nicht
Ah, so
Das ist mir jetzt aber zu dunkel
Bam
Ähm
Okay
Ja, dann lassen wir es so
Ähm, Chat, ich predikte mal
Das wird wieder ganz schlimm
Und ich muss wieder flamen
Weil der wahrscheinlich wieder nur Sachen laufen hat
In Massen, um Sachen laufen lassen zu haben
Und Cluster zum Managen
von anderen Clustern. Unter der Haube
hat er wahrscheinlich sehr wenig
Anwendungen laufen, die ihm was bringen.
Dark zu hell, black zu dunkel.
Ja, ist so. Ich will genau
diese Farbe vom
Twitch-Chat haben.
Oder von meinem Terminal.
Ich finde es ein bisschen blöd,
dass man hier die Background-Color
nicht setzen kann.
Gibt es Custom-Themes? Gibt es auch nicht.
gibt es denn, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal
Chatterino Themes, gibt es da sowas?
Custom, ah, guck mal da
Custom Themes are not yet stable, ist mir doch vollkommen
egal
ob da was stable ist oder nicht
Chatterate
Chatterino
Dracula Theme
Äh, nee, das wird zu kompliziert.
Ich lass es standardmäßig, so wie es ist.
Ist ja auch ein Lab und kein Prot.
Ja, hat er? Hat er denn? Hat er denn überhaupt Prot?
Das ist alles, was er hat.
Und da ist sehr wenig Prot, wo man wirklich sagen kann,
da läuft doch was drauf. Egal, gucken wir uns jetzt an, da kann ich
mir ein bisschen meckern bei.
Immer nicht verkehrt.
Was ist das?
Warum hat der denn da sechs
KVMs dran?
But why?
Ich meine, es sieht cool aus
Okay, jeder
Rechner hat eine eigene
KVM dran, aber
dumme Frage ist
ist der Sinn nicht eigentlich
davon, dass man das umstöpselt?
Also man kann das so machen
Aber du musst ja normalerweise in 99% der Fälle, musst du ja gar nicht per KVM dran. KVM ist ja wirklich nur, wenn du mal ins BIOS musst oder sowas oder zum Initialen einrichten oder halt zum Betriebssystem installieren.
Ja, also keine Ahnung
Ob ich wen kenne?
Wie heißt der?
Ne, kenn ich nicht
Kann man danach suchen?
Ich trau mich nicht hier on stream
Man weiß ja immer nie
Ah, hier.
YouTube.
Token Ring to
Ethernet. Alter, jetzt will er es aber wissen.
Okay.
Du könntest auch einen remote steuerbaren
KVM-Switch dazwischen basteln oder so.
Ja, das wird bestimmt funktionieren. Aber ganz davon
abgesehen,
ähm,
Die einmal im Jahr, wo ich da vielleicht an irgendeine Kiste per KVM dran muss,
dann stöpsel ich das halt einfach mal kurz um.
Also ich finde, jede Kiste in eigener KVM ist total overkill.
Es sieht, okay, da muss man sagen, es sieht cool aus.
Das muss man der Sache lassen.
Und was ich auch cool finde, dass er RGB-Beleuchtung in seinem Rack drin hat.
Ich würde gar nicht so weit gehen, dass RGB-Beleuchtung im Rack komplett useless ist.
Weil, normalerweise hast du es ja so, also auch daheim, ja, du hast eine Lampe, so, und du stehst dann vorm Rack und die Lampe ist quasi schräg hinter dir und verdeckst dir das Licht ein bisschen.
Deswegen finde ich Beleuchtung im Rack selber gar nicht so schlecht.
Also ich bin viel zu faul, sowas zu machen, ja.
Aber
irgendwie steigt da gerade in mir so die
die Bock auf, drauf
RGB in meinen Rack reinzumachen.
Muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Macht er das eigentlich nur für Content oder hat er eine Anwendung für?
Das ist das, was ich ja immer sage.
Ich sehe bei ihm halt einfach die Anwendungsfälle nicht.
Der hat Management für Management zum Managen von Clustern, die Cluster managen.
Und darauf läuft dann am Ende ein Piehole oder sowas.
Egal, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Ich war mit 15 Sekunden im Video, ich habe schon drei Minuten, fünf Minuten gelabert.
None of this would be possible without your support. You genuinely helped make this all happen.
And if you haven't subscribed yet, now's a great time.
I've got an upcoming video where I break down all of the services running in this whole map
and how everything fits together so you won't want to miss it.
And if you know someone who's into whole maps and self-hosting, sharing this video helps a ton.
Alright, let's dive in. Here's my whole map in 2026.
First stop on my tour is this wall of tech.
This wall of tech contains...
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Ähm, irgendwelche Glasfaser-Dinger, würde ich sagen.
Ähm...
Ich hab
äh, Philips, ähm, äh, Lampensteuerung
ist das, oder?
Das sind keine Access Points.
Das sind, äh, irgendwelche Lampendinger.
Warum vier? Keine Ahnung.
Dann hat er hier irgendwie so ein
Unify Switch oder sowas
noch dran.
Ähm
weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Ein Raspberry Pi?
Äh, Kabel?
Internetstelz vielleicht noch?
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas, was da...
Eine Lampe?
Eine Kamera?
Das hier können Nexus Points sein.
Ähm, noch...
Noch ein LoRa-Gateway oder sowas vielleicht?
Mit der großen Antenne hier.
Ja, aber ich rate doch immer gerne, bevor es erklärt wird.
Das hier, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht irgendwas zum Garagensteuern oder so.
Das Ding ist ZigBee, okay.
Was er am Pi hängen hat,
einen Pi Zero nochmal.
Moment, am Pi hängen einen Pi Zero?
Und das hier nochmal PoE, oder?
Äh, okay, das check ich nicht so genau.
Backup-Internet?
Okay.
Zweimal Glasfaser, das ist nicht schlecht, hätte ich auch gerne.
Aber irgendwie kriegt es die Telekom bei mir ja nicht hin, auszubauen.
und ich will ja auch gar nicht zur Telekom.
Da hab ich geiles Cloud-Free-Appearing.
Ich hatte mal Backup-Internet.
Ich hatte eine ganze Zeit Vodafone-Kabel-Internet
und noch einen DSL-Anschluss von der Telekom als Backup,
dass ich schnell umschalten konnte.
Aber nachdem das nie ausgefallen ist,
ich weiß, anscheinend bin ich einer der wenigen,
der nie Probleme mit Vodafone hat.
Und wenn das jetzt so ist, wird es auch in Zukunft nicht so sein,
dann ...
Ich habe es irgendwann abgestellt vor ein paar Jahren schon.
Ich bin bei Vodafone, ja.
Und wenn Vodafone mal großartig Probleme macht, dann kann ich immer noch einen DSL-Anschluss kaufen.
Zusätzlich.
Oh nee, kann ich nicht.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Ich habe keine Telefonleitung mehr.
Die habe ich abgemacht.
dass ich PoE in den Keller kriege.
Die ist weg.
Da müsste ich höchstens...
Aber ich hab die nur abgemacht.
Die liegt noch da.
Also ich könnte die wieder anschließen.
Es liegt ein Kabel,
so ein K7-Kabel,
so ein ganz normales mit 8 Kupferadern drin,
liegt von meinem Serverraum
in Keller und da wurde
am Anfang, wurde darüber nur
zwei Adern benutzt für
die TAE-Dose von der Telekom.
Ich bin im alten Unity Media Gebiet,
ja.
Und
ich brauchte jetzt allerdings
WLAN,
also nicht, ja WLAN ist es,
Ich habe WLAN-Accesspoint im Keller und den per PoE.
Und per Gigabit PoE, da brauchst du halt 8 Kabel, also 8 Adern für.
Und da habe ich selbst vorne, also quasi habe ich das abgemacht bei der Telekom.
oben abgemacht aus der Dose
und ein AJ45 Stecker selbst drauf gekrimpt.
Ich benutze überhaupt kein Telefon mehr.
Leute, wann habt ihr das letzte Mal wirklich einen Telefonhörer am Ohr gehabt?
Also...
Auf meiner neuen Arbeit noch nie. Ich habe da gar kein Telefon mehr auf der neuen Arbeit. Also neue Arbeit, seit drei Jahren bin ich da.
ähm
privat
hatte ich tatsächlich
das Fritz Phone von meiner Mutter
ab und zu mal am Ohr
aber vielleicht, keine Ahnung
vielleicht fünfmal im Jahr oder so
der Rest ist bei mir
rein digital
also es ist ja auch digital, aber
alles über den Computer, ja
irgendeine Mischung aus Discord und Teams oder Handy.
Du hostest dein eigenes Asterix.
Wieso?
Festnetz ist so outdated, overrated.
Na gut, doch.
Ich habe über das Handy schon bei Ärzten auf dem Festnetz angerufen.
Aber das zählt bei mir nicht.
Ich meine, so richtig klassisches, fettes Telefon.
wo man selbst festnetztelefoniert.
Ja, ich mache mal weiter.
Ah, Zigbee ist das.
So I have three play devices.
Ah, der hat vier Fernsehs quasi und diese vier Fernsehgeräte brauchen vier Hubs.
Das machen die doch eigentlich auch nur,
um ordentlich Kohle zu verdienen, oder?
Dass man da für jedes Gerät so ein Device braucht.
Still keep one per play device in order to synchronize the lights to the TV.
Der ist Legende im übertrieben komplizierten Setup haben für warum auch immer.
Aber es ist in der Tat sehr ordentlich.
Ich mag auch diese, wie heißt das, diese perforierten Wände da.
Ich benutze es für Werkzeuge, aber für so Technik-Kram stelle ich mir es auch sehr praktisch vor.
switch to them for backup fiber but not now this is a little sensor unified sensor i was testing
as well motion sensor so just put it up here but it's it's working and it's running down here is
my raspberry pi still have this pie and this is still running this is running nut server
as you can see that's for ups ist das für us v das wirklich ganz nice all of these usb cables
Wie mein Home-Lab gerade aussieht, mehr oder weniger das gleiche wie in meinem letzten Video sieht,
außer dass ein HP Micro Server jetzt im Rack steht, anstatt dieser alte 2 HE 19 Zoll Kiste.
Aber das kommt jetzt ja auch weg und dafür kommt das N5 luftnass hin.
Video mache ich erst mal mit dem Kopf wieder so weit klar bin, dass ich da Bock drauf habe.
Raspberry Pi ist High Hole. Es ist mein Backup DNS für alles was in meinem Server-Rack ist.
Oder ist das nur Backup, falls der alte mal ausfällt?
Okay, whatever.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Hier ist mein HD-Homerun. Das gibt mir eigentlich eine TV über die Luft. Ich habe sie mit Plex verbunden. Es hat vier Kanäle und geht zu einer gigantischen Antenne im Atom. Aber das gibt mir vier Kanäle, um zu schauen, zu recordieren, zu rewinden, live TV, alles zu meinem Plex.
Tja, bei den Amis ist es anscheinend nicht so nervig wie bei uns mit Sendern, die ein Abo wollen und Werbung zeigen und dann noch irgendwie dir verbieten, in Aufnahmen zu spulen.
Sowas gibt es da anscheinend nicht.
In Raspberry Pi Zero als Backup für DNS.
Jaja, kein Nano, Zero.
Also was mit Linux drauf.
Ah, das ist bestimmt.
Ich predikte, das ist für Infrarot-Dinger zum Steuern, aber dann müssten die eigentlich alle sichtbar sein im Serverraum. Das macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
das mit Home Assistant und alles andere, weil meine Schaltkante super dumm ist, also das macht es
smart. Okay, also kommend hierher, das ist mein SM-Lite, SMB, ich weiß nicht, es hat einen wirklich, wirklich langen
Namen, ich kann es nicht erinnern. Das ist ein cooles Gerät, es kann in vielen verschiedenen
I have a video on it, you can check it out.
But it can be configured as a Thread Border Router, as a Bluetooth device to be able to connect to other Bluetooth devices,
a repeater for ZigBee or even a ZigBee Coordinator.
And so I have it configured as a ZigBee Coordinator.
I think I have 84, 85 devices connected over ZigBee, all kinds of devices.
We're talking leak sensors, switches, you know, even this motion sensor up here.
Wenn einer im Video Home Assistant sagt, muss ich immer an diesen anderen Typ denken, der mit der
Klatze, der früher in seinen Videos immer rumgerannt ist und dann geschrien hat, Home Assistant,
Home Assistant. Ich habe vergessen, wie der heißt. Der war überhaupt kein Fan von Home Assistant. Ich
mittlerweile benutzt das selbst hast du mitbekommen dass die neuen iot sachen von
ikea wohl schrott sind ja genau den meine ich genau genau den mal nicht hat warum sind die
ikea sachen schrott die iot sachen ich habe letztens ein video gesehen wo einer gesagt
dass das wäre ganz toll weil günstig und meta und so und die sind schrott aber warum ist es
Schrott, wenn es Meta ist?
Also ich
sehe bei mir absolut keinen Anlass dazu,
Meta einzuführen, ja.
Ich hab noch alte Z-Wave-Geräte
und ZigBee-Geräte, das reicht mir
als Funk-Stelz, da brauch ich nicht noch
ein drittes Funk. Wobei,
Meta über ZigBee ist ja auch
so ein Ding, ne. So
Meta over Threat ist
eigentlich kaum verbreitet.
Verbindungsprobleme die ganze Zeit.
132 SIGPI-Geräte. Boah, das ist ordentlich.
Du hast auch bestimmt einige Steckdosen und sowas als Repeater dazwischen, ne?
Denke ich mal.
Moment, die haben auch was Eigenes.
Es macht Temperatur, Humidität, Licht oder Lumen und dann macht es auch Leak-Detektion.
Ich habe es nicht aufgehängt.
Der hat aber auch alle Funkprotokolle dann am Start.
Für Leak-Detektion, denke ich, braucht man einen anderen Dongle.
Aber sowieso, das ist einer, den ich ausprobiert habe, mit dem Superlink,
der diesen Motionssensor auch verbindet.
Ich habe nicht viel gemacht, außer es ausprobiert.
Ich weiß, dass es eine super lange Range hat.
Die Batterie-Leitung ist auch ziemlich unglaublich.
Und die gleiche Geschichte mit dem.
Das ist eine Siren, die über POE gesteuert wird.
Ich dachte, für Home Security haben die Amis alle ein Stromgewehr im Schrank.
Und eine Shotgun.
Du hast eine ZigBee-Sirene, die ein Lied spielt, wenn ich online...
Wird's ernsthaft?
Das ist ja nice.
Der Wobblos-Alert sozusagen.
Die kannst du aber in Stromsparmodus schicken unter der Woche.
Unter der Woche bin ich ja selten da.
Also außer montags.
Das haben wir jetzt genug.
Ah, jetzt kommen die Switches.
Ich komme ja schon advanced vor
mit meinem
12 plus 4 10 Gig
Switch. Ja, 12 mal
SFP Plus
und vier Aeon 45
10 Gig Ports.
Aber das ist ja wirklich dann schon mal
Next Level da.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich durchdrehen bei der
ganzen, bei dem ganzen Unify Zeug. Ihr wisst,
ich bin kein allzu großer Unify
Fan. Was ich in der Tat
aber ganz nice finde,
sind diese Unify
Kabel. Davon wollte
ich mir tatsächlich auch mal ein Pack bestellen,
weil ich das mega nice finde,
dass die quasi so das Licht vom Port
in den Stecker so
weiterleiten. Ich finde, das sieht irgendwie
hübsch aus.
Was gibt es auch günstig bei FS.com?
Diese Kabel, oder was?
Äh.
Ey, was jetzt?
Jetkill.
Moment, ist da...
Hat das einen Standby-Modus oder sowas?
Wait a minute.
Standby?
Das Standby?
MonkaW, Alter.
Das muss ich ausschalten.
Ähm.
Moment, das ist jetzt voll abgekackt hier.
Das kommt damit nicht klar, dass es im Standby-Modus war.
Moment hier.
Energy, wie schaltet man das aus?
Energy Management?
When inactive, do nothing.
Do nothing.
Never.
Ja.
Bye.
Gut.
Bleibt es an.
Was war das andere hier? Energy?
Energy Consumption Statistic?
Ah ja, würde mich nämlich auch wundern,
woran die herhaben will.
Die Kabel gibt es
günstig bei FS.com.
Nach was muss ich denn da suchen?
Also ich habe hier so...
Ähm...
Ich...
Wie heißen die hier? Patch? Patch Cable?
Von...
Lahnkabel suche finde ich ja alle.
Ich meine die,
die dieses Leuchte-Ding haben.
Ether Light, wie heißt das was?
Ether Light Ding.
Ja.
Das da.
84 Euro für ein 24er Pack.
WTF.
Ah ja.
Und die haben auch Lightning?
Oder wie?
Und wie funzt das jetzt?
Ach, der Switch...
Ja, gut.
Der Switch leuchtet vorne an den...
An den...
Ob connected ist oder nicht.
Also würden die überhaupt...
Also nehmen wir jetzt mal den Switch, den ich hier stehen habe.
CSS, warte mal, was ist das für ein Switch?
CSS 610.
CSS 610, das Ding.
Wenn ich so ein Teil hier hätte,
das geht nur mit Unify.
Ach so.
Also dieses...
Dass die Dinge vorne hier LEDs haben,
das ist den Kabeln egal, oder wie?
Das bringt nix.
Ja, dann ist es natürlich doof.
Ich dachte, das geht mit allen möglichen
Switches, die halt vorne LEDs haben.
Der Switch leuchtet
die Karte. Ja, gut, dann
ist es ja ein sinnloses Feature, ey.
Das brauch ich
nicht.
Das brauch ich nicht.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was?
Das ist aber, wäre aber super weird, Champ, weil das FG ist.
32 von diesen sind 10 GB und 16 von ihnen sind 2,5 GB, was ziemlich unglaublich ist.
Alle unterstützen PoE plus plus.
Also sprich, ein Gig gibt es bei ihm nicht mehr.
Plus plus.
Und der Grund, warum ich zu diesem großen Switch fange, ist, weil...
Das ist aber eigentlich ziemlich nice.
2,5 von diesen sind 10 GB.
Pro XG 48-Port-Switch.
32 von diesen sind 10 GB.
Das ist gar nicht übel.
Aber das braucht man mit der Unify-Gedöns.
Was kostet so was?
Ich meine, ich brauche das nicht.
Ja, ich gucke mal.
USB Pro.
Ne, XG.
XG Pro.
Das Ding, ne?
Das geht eigentlich klar.
Aber das ist der aber nicht.
Das ist der gar nicht.
Das ist der nicht, oder?
Aha.
Ja.
Aber es ist halt auch blöd.
Wisst ihr, was ich mega nice finden würde?
Wenn die...
Das hier sind 10 Gig.
Wenn davon die Hälfte...
Wenn die Hälfte
SFP Plus wäre und die andere Hälfte
RJ45. Das wäre mega.
weil SF4 Plus ist bei 10 Gig einfach
easier zu handeln, ne, also
du kriegst besser Netzwerkkarten dafür,
es braucht
weniger Strom,
gut,
mittlerweile, mittlerweile wird das
besser, jetzt gibt es ja sehr
günstige Realtek
Netzwerkkarten für 10 Gig,
die kosten auch nur, was weiß ich,
13 Euro oder so,
diese mit R45 Stecker,
Mal gucken, bis sie ihre 3x Probleme unter Linux gefixt haben.
Ich will kein Etherlight.
Bei mir kommt kein Unify mehr ins Haus.
Ich mag Unify nicht.
Ich habe selbst den Ubiquiti Switch,
aber das ist ein Edge Switch.
Der ist ohne Unify gedöhnt.
So, gucken wir weiter.
PoE+++.
And so the reason why I jumped to this
big of a switch is because...
Ich hatte vier
Ubiquiti Unify
Access Points.
Es konnte auch sein, dass es nur drei waren.
Ein URP Pro,
eine Nano HD und noch irgendeine...
Ich glaube noch ein Nano HD.
Vielleicht waren es auch nur drei.
Ne.
Die habe ich abgelöst und seitdem kein Uni-File mehr und ich habe auch nicht vor, da irgendwie wieder Uni-File mir zusammenzubasteln.
Was ist denn PoE++++?
100 Watt pro Port. Alter, was hängt denn da dran?
Kannst bald einen Heizlüfter anschließen über POE.
Nein, nicht wirklich. Das braucht nochmal 10 mal mehr.
Hat es ein Handyladen?
Ein NAS?
Aber welches NAS läuft denn bitte schon über POE?
Das Unify NAS?
Okay, aber dann ist ja nicht schlecht.
Wenn die ihre Sachen darauf ausgelegt haben. Weniger Kabel gedünst. Eigentlich ganz gut.
Es unterstützt total vier.
Und ich habe zwei weitere.
Es ist ziemlich ruhig, zumindest jetzt.
Das ist der erste Switch, den ich je gewonnen habe,
wo man den Fan hören kann.
Ubiquiti-Switches sind ziemlich ruhig im Allgemeinen.
Ich habe nie einen Geräusch gehört.
Ich hoffe über PSOX1 und nicht 2.
Das ist der erste Switch, wo ich Geräusche hören werde.
Also im Sommer, wenn es hier wirklich warm wird,
hier. Und dann auf dem Top of that I'm doing a lot of transferring with 10 gig or plug in
some additional 10 gig over Ethernet. The thing will kind of heat up. It's not super
loud by any means. It's not like a Banshee screaming like you hear some of the switches.
Okay, ich mach mal ein bisschen weiter. Es juckt mich jetzt nicht so.
Moving Air, Cloud Key, AI Key, powering lots of devices, powering access points, cameras,
Ich will ja nicht die Stromrechnung sehen, ne?
Zumindest scheint er richtig großer Unify-Fan zu sein.
Wie man Linux lernen kann.
Weißt du, was das Beste aus meiner Sicht ist, um Linux zu lernen?
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz hier hin.
Was aus meiner Sicht das Beste ist, um Linux zu lernen?
Installiere Linux in einer VM.
Und dann benutze das für tägliche Aufgaben.
Das ist das Beste, wie du es lernen kannst.
VM aus dem Grund, dass du es rückstandslos wieder wegkriegst
und dich nicht mit Dual-Boot-Mist auseinandersetzen musst.
VM für tägliche Aufgaben
wie, ich benutze seit Jahren
eine VM für tägliche Aufgaben
das flutscht
habt ihr im Stream schon jemals gedacht
boah, die VM ist aber lahm
da kann man da gar nichts richtig drin machen
das ist wie native
was meinst du mit täglichen Aufgaben
ja das, was du halt so täglich am Computer machst
weißt du, manche schreiben
Word-Dokumente, das kannst du in der Linie nicht machen
Aber nur mit dem Online-Office.
Aber ich programmiere halt was unter Linux.
Ich gucke irgendwelche Netzwerksachen.
Ich bastel Hardware-Kram.
Ich brause im Internet.
Ja, aber das kannst du in der VM vergessen.
beste Distribution zum Einstieg.
Also es gibt aktuell
so ein paar
Hype-Dinger.
Eines der aktuellen,
also ich sag dir, was ich denke,
aber eines der Hype-Sachen,
was OSs angeht, ist aktuell
CacheOS, das ist das, was ich ja auch
gerade verwende.
Find ich eigentlich ganz
nice, ja. Hat mich,
ich dachte ja erstmal so,
Und Mist, wer braucht sowas?
Hat mich aber angesprochen.
Das Schöne ist, dass da ein vollständiges Arch Linux unten drunter ist.
Also das finde ich ganz gut.
CacheOS hat einen guten Installer.
Es kommt auch ganz gut sinnvoll vorkonfiguriert.
Kann man benutzen.
Wenn du einfach nur ein Easy-System zum Einstieg haben willst,
ist die Linux Mint auch auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Kannst genauso gut Linux mitlernen.
Und als drittes ist aktuell auch noch Fedora recht angesagt.
Kann ich aber nichts zu sagen.
ich habe um Fedora immer einen großen Bogen gemacht und irgendwie ist das zurzeit im Trend.
Ich würde sagen, guckt ihr Linux Mint an und dann guckt ihr auch mal CacheOS an, das reicht. Was auch
noch im Hype ist für Gaming aktuell ist Bessit oder wie man das ausspricht und Nubara, dazu kann
ich aber gar nichts sagen ich würde sagen probier mal aus das ganze mit
mit nicht cash cash cash cash so
wenn wir jetzt nicht von desktop reden sondern server da gibt das eigentlich aus meiner sicht
nur eins und das ist debian ich war früher großer ubuntu server fan bin ich nicht mehr kein bock
mehr drauf und alles red hat basierte ist was für enterprise gedöns die viel geld für lizenzen
ausgeben wollen und deswegen einfach debian es gibt zwar so sachen wie wie heißt das alma linux
und rocky linux was quasi red hat nachbau ist aber warum sollte man sich mit red hat auseinandersetzen
wenn es nicht Business Enterprise Gedöns ist
einfach Debian benutzen
Alpine kann man für Containerkrempel
oder sowas verwenden, wobei ich auch
kein Fan von Alpine Containern bin
einfach ein minimal
Debian, wenn es was sein muss, oder
man kann es auch einfach from scratch oder Distroless
machen, also nicht Linux from scratch
diesen Scratch Container, kann es einfach
wenn es die Anwendung hergibt
ansonsten ein kleines Debian tut
genauso, die paar MB tun nicht weh
versus ein Alpine OS
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen
VM und Container?
Das Wort Container
ist
finde ich ein bisschen
unglücklich.
Das muss ich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen länger
ausholen. Moment, wartet mal Leute, ich mach mal
kurz hier eine Runde Musik wieder an.
Ich finde das Wort Container
ein bisschen unglücklich,
weil Container
im Kopf,
ja, also,
die Leute wissen oftmals, so eine
VM ist halt so quasi ein virtueller Computer
und ein Container ist das nicht auch irgendwie ein virtueller
Also, ich finde, Container
schafft viel zu viel Nähe zu
VM, dieser Begriff.
Letztendlich
ist ein Container
eigentlich eine Zusammenwirken
von verschiedenen
kernel funktionalitäten was linux zur verfügung stellt hauptsächlich namespaces und cgroups das
heißt wenn du was im container startest dann gibt es diesen container es gibt kein container in dem
sinn ja es gibt ein paar funktionen im linux körner die das ermöglichen was man unter container
zusammenfasst ein prozess den du in einem container startest oder also wenn ich jetzt
jetzt lsla mache hier drin oder sandbox in einem container ist es egal das ist
ein prozess der ganz normal unter meinem linux kernel läuft das ist kein
unterschied außer dass ein bisschen cgroups und namespaces gedulds drum
herum ist also du kannst auch wenn du wenn du einen prozess ausführst in einem
container und guckst dann hier bei ps siehst du den auch drin also letztendlich kann man sich
kann man sich das so vorstellen ein container oder das was man unter dem container zusammenfasst ist
im endeffekt so ein bisschen sandbox funktionalität die der linux können bereitstellt für prozesse die
du startest da ist nichts virtualisiert und auch erste mal gar nicht so großartig isoliert je nach
dem wie man es macht also es ist einfach ein weiterer prozess in deinem linux können wie
alles andere auch nur dass man dem mit können funktionen bisschen was vorgaukeln kann so im
gegensatz zu einer vm vm ist tatsächlich ein eigener kölner läuft hat nichts mit einem haus
kölner zu tun und virtuelle hardware virtuelle grafikkarte virtuelle netzwerkkarte das einzige
was bei einer vm nicht wirklich virtualisiert ist es die cpu deswegen ist die cpu performance
zwischen der vm und dem host auch gar nicht so großartig unterschiedlich der größte unterschied
zwischen vm und container wenn man mal auf performance guckt ist ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
so sieht gar nicht so sehr die cpu performance sondern der ram verbrauch bei einer vm brauchst
du halt deutlich mehr bei der vm wird ein komplett eigener kernel gestartet es wird
hardware virtualisiert und das muss alles doppelt und dreifach laufen pro vm das heißt wenn du
einfach nur den prozess starten willst dann braucht das in einem container das gleiche
wenn du es auf seinem haus starten würdest weil es wird auf deinem haus gestartet das macht eigentlich
nahezu keinen unterschied also braucht ein prozess 200 mb ram dann braucht er im container auch 200
mb ram in der vm sieht das anders aus in der vm muss dann komplett linux können starten und es
muss virtualisierungs geduld drum herum laufen dann brauchst du mehr da brauchst du 200 mb von
einem prozess und ich sag mal mindestens noch einmal 128 dass du wirklich sehr minimalistische
vm laufen lassen kannst gleich geht es mit trick 17 auch mit 64 mb aber eher nicht ja und das muss
da wirklich schon eine super minimale vm sein dass du damit 128 mb auskommt also da kannst
jetzt nicht einfach sagen ich lass da irgendwie ein vollwertiges db mit ein paar sachen drauf
laufen ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich ein db an server mit 128 mb ram überhaupt gebootet
kriege wahrscheinlich schon db an ist sehr minimalistisch weiß ich weiß nicht was minimal ram
Weiß nicht, was das minimale Arbeitsspeicher braucht.
Ja, 500, 200, 250.
Minimum Hardware Requirements.
Guck, die sagen, mindestens sollst du 250 MB RAM haben.
Das heißt, du brauchst noch einmal zusätzlich das Doppelte an RAM, was dein Prozess bräuchte.
Also RAM-Verbrauch ist ehrlich gesagt das, was man mit Containern spart, hauptsächlich.
Es ist gar nicht so sehr die CPU-Performance.
Die sind ja vor allem auch ziemlich gut.
Aber RAM, also generell, was du an Speicherverbrauch hast.
disk speicher ssd speicher und ram das brauchst du in der vm deutlich mehr als wenn du wenn du
was mit container benutzt container brauchen halt im endeffekt einfach so gut wie nichts mehr
bisschen container image ein bisschen mehr platten speicher brauche ram usage ist genau das gleiche
und in der vm brauchst du halt linux was läuft und du musst es ja auch irgendwo speichern und
starten also brauchst ssd speicher dafür und noch mal ram für den kölner und die virtualisierungs
funktionen also auf etwas memory angeht und disks und sowas ist halt bei der vm enorm und das im
großen stil macht halt sehr viel aus wenn ihr euch vorstellt ihr habt irgendeine anwendung
die ganz gut wie man so schön enthori zorn thal skaliert dankeschön für den sub exzellente
subscription kann ein container modules laden ein privilege container vielleicht bin ich ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht so sicher aber in der regel muss der hauskörner schon bereitstellen start up time
start up time ist auch ein riesen ding ja start up time aber das macht halt viel aus wenn man
stellt euch mal vorher eine anwendung die gut horizontal skaliert wie man das so schön denn
Also horizontale Skalierung ist immer gemeint, du kannst einfach vieles vom Gleichen nebeneinander stellen.
Also du kannst die Anwendung zweimal laufen lassen oder 300 Mal.
Das ist dann horizontal skaliert.
Vertikal skaliert wäre, du hast die Anwendung zweimal laufen und du lässt einfach dann in Zukunft auch zwei laufen,
aber die kriegen stärkere Hardware.
Das wäre dann vertikal skaliert.
Wenn du was hast, was dich gut horizontal skalieren lässt, zum Beispiel eine Web-Anwendung oder sowas,
wobei es da mit der datenbank tatsächlich probleme geben wir mal von aus du hast eine
anwendung die sich super skalieren lässt ja und jetzt hast du 22 mal die anwendung laufen dann
macht pewdiepie ein video über deine anwendung und auf einmal hast du anstatt 200 user 200.000
user und dann werde ich dann skaliert du das ganze vertikalen sagt okay ich lasse die anwendung
einfach nicht zweimal laufen, sondern ich lasse die Anwendung einfach 100 Mal laufen.
Ja, schön und gut, das kannst du machen.
Wenn du das mit Containern machst, brauchst du die Ressourcen,
die 100 Mal diese Anwendung braucht.
Machst du es in der VM, brauchst du 100 Mal die Ressourcen,
die die Anwendung braucht, plus 100 Mal die Ressourcen,
die du brauchst, um die Anwendung in der VM laufen zu lassen.
Also sprich, wenn man jetzt mal bei Debian Mindestvoraussetzungen geht,
mindestens 100 mal 256 MB RAM.
Ist jetzt
machbar, aber kostet schon ein bisschen Geld,
gerade in der heutigen Zeit.
Also da macht das schon dick was aus.
Wenn man jetzt Anwendungen hat,
die, also im Heimbereich,
wo du eine Anwendung
von einem Typ einmal laufen hast,
dann würde ich das
danach machen, was im Handling für dich einfacher ist.
In der Regel ist aber Container-Handling auch einfacher als extra VMs, weil VMs musst du regelmäßig Betriebssystem-Updates machen, Package-Updates machen und alles mögliche.
Bei manchen Sachen macht es aber auch durchaus Sinn, das isoliert in der VM zu betreiben.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du explizit ein Hardware-Passthrough brauchst.
Wenn du jetzt PCI-Express-Geräte durchreichen willst an der VM, so exklusiv an die VM, dann ist das in der VM natürlich besser als im Container.
container ist das halt alles schert
ja also muss man sich angucken was da für
den jeweiligen anwendungsfall besser ist sonst habe ich lange ausgeholt
wenn man nicht sicher ob man das alles soweit gecheckt hat hat es dir gereicht
als erklärung ich mag diese vergleichsbilder nicht wir können uns ja mal angucken naja das
das finde ich das finde ich auch super verwirren diese bilder man muss man muss einfach sehen das
ist kein unterschied für den linux können jetzt erste mal oder für das wie du eine anwendung
laufen lässt ob das im container laufen lässt oder auf deinem haus also war es mal beispiel
Beispiel, okay? Hier, Docker run.
Habe ich überhaupt jemals schon mal Docker-Container gestartet?
Docker run, äh,
minus, minus, äh, minus, äh.
Ich habe nicht mal Docker installiert hier drauf.
Neue VM am Start, Alter.
Docker.
Das muss auf jeden Fall drauf hier.
Machen wir das doch mal.
Docker.
So.
System
CTL
Enable
Docker
Die ist es?
Okay, minus minus now
Warum?
Ah, weil ich Kernupdate gemacht habe, kann das sein?
Oh yeah
Ich habe Kernupdate gemacht, Leute.
Ich muss rebooten.
Das Docker funktioniert.
Reboot.
Ein Reboot
machen wir mal schnell.
Genau.
Container sind sinnvoll, wenn du RAM und
Diskusage sparen willst.
Also das ist mal
aus Performance-Sicht, ja.
Ähm, für Skalierbarkeit
sind Container auch besser, weil, guck mal,
du kannst viel einfacher 100 Container starten
als 100 VMs.
100 VMs, da musst du erstmal dein Linux drauf
kriegen, da müssen die Dinger erstmal starten,
das dauert ja auch alles. Also wenn du
das schnell skalieren willst, sind Container auf jeden Fall
deutlich besser. Und mit so
Orchestrator-Sachen wie Kubernetes
geht da auch vieles automatisch.
Äh, ups.
Chatke, ich habe die falsche Kiste gestartet.
Ich glaube, ich sollte es mal umstellen.
Ich stelle das mal um.
Jetzt gehen wir ins BIOS und stellen das mal um.
Ist das System Deboot?
Ne, das ist Limein oder wie das heißt.
Wie verbindest du dich auf den PC jetzt?
KVM-Switcher oder ist das jetzt eine VM?
Das ist ein echter Mini-PC, an den ich gerade meine Tastatur dran gestöpselt habe,
weil der auf meinem anderen PC steht.
Sonst würde ich ja nicht ins BIOS kommen.
Da habe ich gerade meine Tastatur dran gestöpselt.
Wenn ich Linux gestartet habe,
mache ich mit Synergy oder einem Synergy Fork
Desktop Maus- und Tastatursharing.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
einstellen, Boot-Reihenfolge.
Wir wollen als erste Boot-Option...
Ne, Moment, hier, das will ich haben.
NVMe-Drive.
Das da will ich als erste Boot-Option haben.
Und wie kommst du dann ins Windows?
Aktuell komme ich gar nicht ins Windows, weil meine Tastatur nicht am Windows dran gestöpselt ist.
Ich boote jetzt das Ding.
Ich boote jetzt das Ding und dann stöpsel ich meine Tastatur wieder an meinen Windows-PC.
Äh.
Habe ich mein Passwort nicht eingetippt?
Okay.
Aha.
Jetzt stöpsel ich das wieder an mein Windows-PC.
Und jetzt kann ich hier hin und her...
Was?
hat mir das kölner ab der jetzt das system zerschossen oder was
Ich habe, ich bote glaube ich von der falschen SSD, oder?
Ich bote von der falschen SSD.
Ich habe irgendeinen Mist eingestellt im BIOS gerade.
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Linker Bildschirm Windows, rechter Linux-PC.
Ne, ne, ich zeige es dir gleich, wie ich das habe.
Bote ich mal das hier?
So, Passwort.
Lass mich eintippen.
Please enter Passwort.
Moment, ist das jetzt eine andere Disc, Leute?
Was will der denn von mir?
Das Passwort ist...
Sag mal!
Hat mir das Kernel-Update
das System kaputt gemacht, oder was?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wartet mal.
Jetzt muss ich das gerade nochmal umstellen.
Das Passwort für mein Stream-OS ist stream.
Das ist easy und kurz.
Also das hier ist eigentlich die Platte.
Ah, ich kann es ja nochmal umstellen.
Was, ist der Drench eigentlich egal?
Wird der Screen tauschen?
Was soll ich denn leaken?
Ich kann ja nichts leaken.
snapshots
Ja okay ist ich habe noch snapshots da kann ich theoretisch zurückrollen sollte es jetzt nicht funktionieren gucken wir mal
Ich starte markt us lts vielleicht irgendwas abgekackt irgendwas können
War das nicht so, dass du ein privates
und zuerst hast du ein Steam-OS? Ja, habe ich.
Aber ich kann auf gar keinen Fall auf das
private OS zugreifen, weil es ein anderes
Passwort hat für die Disk.
Was will der denn?
What the fuck?
Scheiße, warum ist das jetzt im Arsch?
Oh, es kann sein, dass ich mich vertippt habe die ganze Zeit.
Postchamp? Postchamp?
Okay, ich bin glaube ich einfach nur zu beschränkt, mein Passwort zu tippen.
Leute, ich bin einfach nur zu beschränkt, mein Passwort zu tippen.
Scheiße.
Ich habe...
Mein Passwort ist stream.
Stream.
Ja, stream.
Und ich habe die ganze Zeit Steam eingegeben.
Und mich gewundert, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Okay, Leute, ich kann euch mein Setup jetzt zeigen.
Also, guckt mal. Ganz einfach.
Also, dieses Rebooten lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor, okay?
So wie es ist, wenn Linux gestartet ist.
Also, ich habe hier auf meinem PC, auf meinem Gaming-PC, habe ich Windows laufen.
Ich habe einen zweiten Desktop unter Windows konfiguriert, okay?
Zweiten Desktop.
Auf den zweiten Desktop switche ich jetzt mal rüber.
Auf dem zweiten Desktop läuft ein OBS.
Das seht ihr aber nicht.
Das läuft da im Fullscreen.
Also guckt, erster Desktop Windows, zweiter Desktop Windows.
Immer noch unter Windows.
Deswegen kann ich ja auch in OBS rumklicken.
So weit klar.
So, und was ich jetzt eingerichtet habe ist,
ich habe hier Deskflow laufen.
Deskflow ist ein Maus- und Tastatursharing-Tool von Windows zu Linux und Linux zu Windows.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt rüber switche über dieses Deskflow auf die Linux-Kiste, seht ihr,
dann wird meine Maus und Tastatur weitergeleitet auf die Linux-Kiste.
Ihr seht es jetzt hier im OBS.
Das seht ihr normalerweise nicht, weil Fullscreen.
So, und normalerweise habe ich hier wie meine VM sonst einfach wieder zweiten Bildschirm Fullscreen.
und jetzt switch ich hier rüber und was ich jetzt
eingerichtet habe ist
das geht über die Elgato mit 240 Hertz
das ist saumäßig flüssig
ich merke hier überhaupt kein Lack
so und was ich jetzt gebaut habe ist
Trick 17, ich habe in meiner
Logitech Software
habe ich ein Makro
hinterlegt
ach, nach 3 Stunden lädt er das
dann irgendwann auch
oder auch nicht
habe ich ein Makro hinterlegt auf F1 und F2. F1 drückt linke Windows-Taste und Control und dann nach rechts.
Das ist die Standard-Shortcut, um Desktops unter Windows zu switchen.
und dann drückt er alt-a
alt-a bedeutet
ist ein Shortcut in
Deskflow, bedeutet switche
den Desktop 1 nach rechts
so und so habe ich das dann eingerichtet
hier das andere geht nach links
und drückt den Shortcut nochmal
und jetzt drücke ich F2 und dann switcht er
auf den zweiten Desktop und
gibt die Maus rüber an die
Linungskiste
der zweite Linungskiste, ne der zweite
Desktop
der der zweite desktop ist ein mini pc mit linux ein steht das hier irgendwie ein b-link
sr 7 irgendwas mit einer reisen mit einem 8 core 16 threads reisen und nach 780 m dass das setup
ist umständlich ja deswegen ist das soweit automatisiert wie geht bis jetzt geht bestimmt
noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber ist für mich halt das optimale
Setup, weil ich will ja
alles sehen, was ihr seht auf dem Bildschirm.
Und ich will meinen Vorschau-Rechner haben, um hier
Bilder und Sachen
und Zeug abspielen
zu können.
Mein zweiten
Vorschau-Rechner für Steam,
der steht hier nebendran, hier links,
neben dem, wo jetzt der Mauszeiger ist, steht der.
Der hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist kein KVM-Switch. Das stimmt doch
überhaupt nicht, Chat.
Erzähl doch nichts. Kein KVM-Switch.
Das ist ein Linux-Mini-PC.
Der wird über
eine Capture-Card
gecaptured,
der Linux-Desktop, und hier
angezeigt auf meiner Windows-Kiste.
Deswegen siehst du hier
auf dem ersten Desktop
Windows und auf dem zweiten Desktop
das ist eigentlich ein Windows-Desktop,
siehst du einen Fullscreen
Fullscreen
Capture über die Capture Card.
Deswegen ist ja auch jetzt hier die Maus
noch Windows und erst wenn ich sage,
pack die Maus rüber auf
Linux, dann ist sie hier.
Das geht über
Deskflow.
Das ist ein Tool, da kann man
zwischen verschiedenen Rechnern Maus und Tastatur
sharen.
Ein Ragebait-Emote.
Wie zum Teufel kommt es jetzt auf das C++ Video?
Ja, das Rageblade-Emote gefällt mir nicht.
Max macht bestimmt irgendwann ein Do-It-Yourself von seinem...
Das ist schwierig!
Wir haben ja im Stream viele schon gemacht.
Aber ich hab's ja dann am Laufen.
Das zu zeigen, was am Laufen ist, ist schwierig.
Hast du wirklich?
Das ist überhaupt nicht die aktuellste Version.
Aber das finde ich cool, dass du das gemacht hast.
By the way, ich brauch das jetzt ja gar nicht mehr, ne?
Ich brauch das ja nicht mehr unter Linux.
Weil, guck mal hier.
Das funzt ja nach wie vor
Weil das ja eigentlich nur ein OBS ist
Was ihr hier seht
Das ist nach wie vor unter Windows
Ich kann quasi mein Kram weiterhin anzeigen
Das kann weiter .NET Framework 4.8 bleiben
Und ich fasse es nie wieder an
Das finde ich gut.
Das machen wir.
Irgendwas mit...
Du hast recht, ja.
Der sidetracked ohne Ende.
Aber konfirm.
Genau, ich wollte eigentlich was zu Container zeigen.
Richtig.
Also, Docker, PS...
Achso, Orchard.
Ich kann es...
Senior Linux Admin, by the way.
User Mod minus A minus G.
Docker. Max.
Docker PS.
Äh, warum geht das nicht?
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß warum.
Äh, ups.
Ich glaube, ich weiß warum.
Weil, genau, weil ich erstmal die Session neu starten müsste.
Aber so geht es jetzt auch.
Docker PS
So, also Docker run
Minus, minus, minus, minus
Boah, das ganze Kram ist auswendig
Nehmen wir jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Debian
Stable, oder ne, Debian
Trixie, muss man sagen, ne
Trixie, äh, bin, bash
Ging das so?
Hoffe ich mal
Ne
Äh, einfach nur bin, bash
Ohne minus, minus, okay
Also, guck mal hier.
Ich starte jetzt mal was auf meinem Host.
Wir machen ein zweites Tab auf, okay?
Also, hier, zweites, zweites Tab.
Ich starte mal ein Programm hier auf meiner Liedungskiste.
Wenn ich jetzt danach kreppe, siehst du...
Es läuft.
Wir können es übrigens so kreppen, dass das sonst nicht rumhört.
Du siehst, es läuft. Das Programm, yes, läuft.
Ja?
das ist ein ganz normaler Prozess,
ganz normaler Prozess,
hier in meinem Linux Kernel,
als Child Process von meiner Shell,
siehst du, hier läuft,
so, und jetzt mache ich das hier mal aus,
und jetzt starte ich das mal im Container,
das ist jetzt hier im Debian Container,
und du wirst sehen,
es läuft, du siehst es hier,
guck,
du siehst das hier,
Und du siehst das, weil das einfach ein weiterer Prozess ist, der auf deinem gleichen Linux-Kernel wie alles andere läuft.
Da ist jetzt ein bisschen Namespacing, ein bisschen C-Group, Sandboxing drumherum, aber es ist ein Prozess, der läuft in dem gleichen Kernel, wie wenn du es direkt auf deiner Linux-Kiste ausschüttest.
Das heißt, ein Container ist nichts, was irgendwie was Eigenes startet, wie eine VM, sondern es ist einfach nur ein bisschen Sandboxing drumherum, von dem man übrigens vieles auch gar nicht benutzen muss.
was ist was das hier ist das ist feife time das problem ist doch oftmals kennt ihr das kennt ihr
das problem auch genau das problem wenn ihr was krebs sich selber findet so und das hier ist
regex das ist eine zeichen gruppe die nur nur jy die nur y beinhaltet und im prinzip klappt es
exakt nach dem gleichen nur dadurch dass im grepp output also er findet das ja
weil grepp yes ist jetzt enthalten und jetzt ist im grepp eben nicht jetzt
enthalten sondern klammer auf y klammer zu es und das heißt er kennt nur noch
nach den sachen die wirklich jetzt heißen weil nicht mehr jetzt in krebs
Träne vorkommt. Versteht man
jetzt, was ich meine?
Das ist ein ganz alter Trick, um
Krebs sich selbst auszutricksen.
Damit flext du
auf der Arbeit, Beste.
Wie viel IQ man
braucht, um darauf zu kommen. Ganz geringen IQ.
Wobei das hier kein Problem
ist, durch die ganzen Subs heute und sowas.
Und Follows und alles
haben wir wirklich heute wieder den IQ
richtig hart gesteigert.
Das habe ich mir aber
nicht selbst ausgedacht.
Das habe ich irgendwo mal gelesen und seitdem benutze ich es.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch noch was.
Noch was Neues.
Eines meiner Lieblingstools.
Ich mache das mal hier gerade wieder aus.
Ja, Cramp-V kann man
übrigens genauso machen.
Also das ist eigentlich so das Ding, das machen auch viele.
Geht genauso.
Übrigens, eines meiner Lieblingstools, was ich euch mal zeigen wollte, ist...
PV ist installiert.
PV. PV ist ein richtig geiles Tool.
Ihr kennt doch bestimmt das Problem.
Ihr wollt, ihr kopiert irgendwas.
Oder ihr macht irgendwas auf der Shell, was selbst keine Progress-Anzeige hat.
DD früher zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich erkläre gerne sowas, Grapefruitlauf.
Wenn du Fragen hast, hau immer rein, Leute.
Geht an alle, ne?
An SD Company, dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier.
Pog.
Also, früher hatte die Idee kein Progress.
Also, ihr kennt das Ding ja.
Wenn ihr irgendwie Progress anzeigen wollt,
aber das Ding kann kein Progress.
So, machen wir mal zum Beispiel hier.
Cat, Dev, Zero.
Okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen blöd.
Okay, machen wir es mal wirklich so.
So, ihr wollt jetzt mal gucken, wie schnell ist eure SSD, indem ihr da einfach Nullen draufschreibt.
Ja?
So.
Da könntet ihr sagen, cat dev 0 gepiped nach blub.bin.
Jetzt schreibt ihr ganz viele Zeros auf die SSD.
Ja, ihr könnt jetzt natürlich mit htp gucken, was das Ding für eine I.O. macht.
Und dann seht ihr, okay, es ist eigentlich abfacklangsam.
Und jetzt ist es auf einmal saumäßig schnell.
1,5 Gig die Sekunde.
Ich brech mal ab, dass es nicht zu voll wird.
Das ist Mist.
So, was ihr jetzt machen könnt, ihr könnt Cat nehmen, das nach PV pipen und PV dann umleiten nach Lobbin.
Und schon seht ihr, Alter, was mit meiner Maus?
Und schon seht ihr, wie viel da durchgeht. Guckt mal da.
Und wenn ihr jetzt noch advancer seid, lasst ihr das Cat sogar weg und macht Input Redirection und sagt Def Zero so.
Das ist der Pro-Weg, ja?
Input umleiten von DevZero nach PV und PV-Output umleiten nach Blubbin.
Und da seht ihr, meine SSD macht so irgendwas um 1,4548.
Ich habe übrigens auch was Cooles, was ich in letzter Zeit öfters verwendet habe.
Das muss ich mir jetzt aber nochmal bei Google suchen,
weil ich meine Bash-Historie hier noch nicht hab.
Was ich auch cool finde...
Achso, das geht übrigens auch anderweitig, ne?
Also wenn ihr sowas macht wie dd
if
def0
of gleich
hat nix mit Onlyfans zu tun,
dann habt ihr jetzt ja auch kein Progress
bei dd.
Gibt's nicht. Mittlerweile gibt es
äh...
Status Progress gibt es mittlerweile
bei dd, ja?
Gab es früher beispielsweise nicht.
Man sieht, das ist ganz schön lahm.
Ganz schön lahm.
Man könnte es auch so machen.
Man könnte das hier nehmen.
DD.
DD muss übrigens nicht, das ist auch sowas.
DD muss nicht in einem Kommando laufen.
Also es geht auch sowas hier.
DD nach PV und dann nach DD.
Das funktioniert auch.
Also ihr müsst nicht DD, IF und OF im gleichen Kommando haben.
Guck und jetzt sagt euch PV auch, wie viel da drüber geht.
Da stellt ihr jetzt fest, das ist ganz schön lahm.
Und das liegt daran, dass die Blocksize nicht richtig eingestellt ist.
Schreiben wir die Blocksize mal auf 4 MB, da ist das Ganze schon mal ein bisschen schneller.
Und Cat hat nichts mit Katze zu tun, genau.
So sieht das Ganze aus.
So.
Und dann wollte ich euch noch was Cooles zeigen.
Weil manchmal hat man ja unter Linux das Bedürfnis,
man möchte random daten generieren und damit was testen ja manchmal ist
beispielsweise der zero nicht so tolle der zero ist beispielsweise bei
dateisystemen oder sachen mit komprimierung oder oder die platte die
application nicht so tolle weil sie oder meistens gar nichts macht da kann man
dann so was benutzen wie der freunde oder der view rände man sieht schon das
ist ganz schön lahm.
Der random, der few random.
Also da sieht man, das ist nicht so schnell.
Was viel schneller ist, um random Daten zu
generieren unter Linux, ist,
da muss ich jetzt aber gucken,
ist
OpenSSL.
Wir fragen mal ChatGPT, wie das war.
OpenSSL
Rant.
example genau number bites ex kann man auch machen das aber eigentlich auch
wurscht genau so das generiert jetzt random 16 random bites so aber was man
jetzt mal also das ist natürlich dementsprechend jetzt so schnell wenn ich
das nach der 0 peipe so das soll so jetzt machen wir hier mal hier keine
9999999
immer noch relativ schnell
so und jetzt hat man nahezu beliebig viel Random
und kann tatsächlich mal gucken
was Random so durchgeht
und das dürfte jetzt wahrscheinlich
vom Arbeitsspeicher irgendwie ein bisschen limitiert sein
guck ich krieg
mit 4,73
ne
das ist Single Core
Performance limitiert
das OpenSSL hat 100% auf 1 CPU
kann jetzt ich kann bis zu 4,4 gigabytes pro sekunde random daten generieren das
heißt wenn ich das jetzt ausprobieren will auf meine platte club punkt bin
dann sieht man okay damit ist es so eine ganze ecke langsamer also random daten
schreiben ist tatsächlich ein bisschen langsamer als sie raus schreiben das ist
viel besser zum random daten generieren als der view random und der fremden wenn
schnell gehen muss
so chat sonst noch irgendwelche high iq linux questions
ich habe chat arena oder nicht wieder angemacht
was gibt's heute zu essen heute gibt es nicht nudeln mit lachs
Ich glaube, es gibt noch übrig geblieben Kartoffelsalat.
Können wir Low IQ Linux durchgehen? Können wir auch.
Wenn du Low IQ Linux Fragen hast, auch her damit.
Das kenne ich gar nicht. Was macht denn INAV?
Max, wie stehen die Chancen
auf Nachmittagstream heute?
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage.
Weiß ich nicht.
Nicer Shit, aber du wirst einsam sterben.
Ja, ich mach kein Hehl drum, dass ich das übelste Kellerkind bin.
Aber immerhin.
Ein Kellerkind mit einem VO2 Max von, ich glaub, 48.
Oder was hab ich als letztes gehabt? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Habe ich irgendwann mal auf Twitter gepostet.
NixOS ist immutable.
Das finden manche Leute geil, ich nicht.
Warum findet das Google nicht mehr?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Warum das Nitta nicht mehr findet?
War es nicht eigentlich .com?
Ansonsten?
So, wartet mal.
Hier.
Max.
Wo habe ich denn...
Jetzt wollte ich einmal flexen.
Mit
Trainings-Images.
Boah, da hätte ich jetzt Bock drauf,
Leute, heute. Alter, hätte ich da Bock drauf.
Vielleicht ist mein...
Vielleicht habe ich euch auch Mist erzählt mit dem
Power 2 Max.
Welche Debian-Distro ist für dich die
nicestste Empfehlenswelt? Bin gerade auf der Suche.
Für Desktop gar keine.
Für den Server immer Debian Stable.
Fertig. Stable.
Debian Stable, ne?
Wo ist mein VO2 Max
Flex? Sagt mir, wenn ihr
ihn irgendwo seht.
Jetzt wäre Infinite Scroll tatsächlich nicht
verkehrt. Ah, guck mal hier.
Chatkill.
45 war es. 45.
Da haben wir
fast das gleiche McFly. Nicht 48,
45. Guck mal, ich bin
Ich bin 1, 1 vor sehr gut.
Ne, weiß ich nicht, lange nichts mehr gehört.
Und das ist für mein Alter gar nicht schlecht.
Für fast 42 ist das ziemlich gut.
Das ist ein Fitness, also somit der beste Fitnesswert, den man für einen Fitnesszustand haben kann.
Also dieses VO2 Max.
Das ist, wenn ich es richtig zusammenkriege,
die Menge an Sauerstoff, die du quasi in Leistungsoutput verwandeln kannst.
Womit misst du den? Mit einer Garmin-Uhr.
Die misst das natürlich nicht direkt, weil die mir keine Nadel in den Arm rammt.
Wie du den positiv beeinflussen kannst,
eher Sport machen.
Das Max steht für beides.
Ja, egal.
Genug.
Gibt es da auch Minuswerte?
Ne.
Wenn du Minuswerte hast,
dann bist du tot.
Es dauert einfach ein bisschen.
Also was auf jeden Fall was bringt, was ich gemerkt habe, ist, wenn man nicht immer nur gleich rennt, ja.
Also wenn man eine gute Mischung hat aus so mittleren Strecken, mal einmal die Woche eine lange Strecke,
zwischendurch mal ein bisschen Intervallrennen oder so, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich bin da aber auch zu nubig für.
ich lasse mir einen Trainingsplan von
der Garmin App generieren
ja und das ist dann meistens so
dass
also wenn ich mich da komplett dran halten würde
was ich in letzter Zeit nicht komplett mache
ist es so
es ist eigentlich meistens 5 oder 6 Tage
die Woche
wird gerannt
wenn es jetzt wieder schöner wird
werde ich auch ab und zu mal Fahrradfahren wieder
einstreuen dabei
also fünf sechs tage die woche wird gerannt ein tag ist eigentlich immer frei
nicht mit dem garmin coach mit diesem normalen trainingsplan generator da so
aber da macht dann immer eine ganz schöne mischung aus man kann auch
einstellen wann man länger laufen will er macht dann meistens samstag sonntag
rum plante einen long run das grenze dann relativ langsam dafür dann irgendwie
so 13 14 kilometer je nachdem was halt so eineinhalb stunden packst
dann macht das ab und zu auch mal Intervalle rein,
unterschiedliche Sachen, so nach dem Motto,
mal nur 10 Sekunden, dafür viel, viel schnellerer Pace,
mal eine Minute, dafür nur medium schnellerer Pace
und dann eine Minute Pause und sowas oder langsam weiterlaufen.
Also ich finde diesen Trainingsplangenerator von Garmin echt nice,
muss ich sagen.
Also finde ich gut.
Kann man sich auch als Kack-Noob wie ich danach richten
und das hilft.
Aber man muss natürlich
sagen, man wird jetzt nicht innerhalb von
zwei Jahren
auf irgendwie
50 plus
da V2 Max oder so kommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jemals schaffen werde.
Keine Ahnung. Ich bin aber schon ganz
froh, dass ich wenigstens jetzt in
einem Bereich bin, dass ich so bei den
Top 30 meines Alters angelangt
bin. Das reicht mir voll und ganz. Wenn ich
überlege wie ich noch wie krass untrainierter kaknub ich vor vier jahren
oder 34 jahren war da ist bin ich jetzt mit allem schon zufrieden
ich gehe nicht ins gym wie lange ist eine fahrradstrecke das ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr ich glaube max von keine ahnung 36 oder so also richtig mies was
ich bin fast zwei ich werde dieses jahr 42 die lange wie lange die fahrradstrecke
ist das hängt ein bisschen davon ab was ich mache also die standard runde die
ist glaube ich so 32 kilometer oder so die kann man immer mal fahren das ganz
nice das geht dann so ein bisschen über
feldweg wald und und straße ein stückchen und dann das ist ganz gut die
Die sind um die 32 Kilometer.
Die Standardrunde, die ich gerne fahre.
Und 32 Kilometer ist halt auch so eine Strecke, die kann man immer fahren.
Und ansonsten, ich weiß gar nicht, was das längste war bisher.
Weiß ich gar nicht genau.
Also ich kann euch sagen, dass nach Frankfurt und zurück sind so ungefähr 60 Kilometer.
Also zusammen.
Und das längste, was ich gefahren bin, ist hier mal Richtung Spessart.
So einen Berg hoch und zurück.
Das dürfte knapp unter 100 gewesen sein, glaube ich.
So irgendwie 80 oder so.
Weiß ich jetzt aber gar nicht genau.
86 oder sowas.
ja hey leute wo ich auf youtube angefangen haben 25 haben alle gedacht
ich bin zwölf oder so ist also
kraft sport habe ich irgendwie gar keinen bock drauf ich habe jetzt in der
tat allerdings mal überlegt ob ich nicht doch ab und zu mal was machen sollte
weil ich habe sehr viele videos gesehen wo es darum ging das beste was man
machen kann um besser zu werden im rennen ist regelmäßige wie haben sie
das auf englisch genannt core strength übungen weiß ich was was heißt es auf
deutsch also chor ist ja so nicht die mitte so das kern vom karl wie man das
auf deutsch heißt.
Rumpf, genau, Rumpf.
Das habe ich mir überlegt,
ab und zu mal, vielleicht wäre das nicht verkehrt.
So, aber gut.
Chat. Jetzt sind wir komplett
Zeit getrackt. Übrigens, wo wir
gerade dabei sind,
wo wir gerade beim Thema Fahrrad sind,
bevor die Frage noch kommt, das ist mein Fahrrad.
Früher gab es doch diese Werbung, Leute.
Mein Haus, mein Auto, mein Boot.
Wir machen jetzt mein Fahrrad, meine Linux,
vor allem mein Twitch-Chat.
Ist das mein Fahrrad hier.
Bin ich auch sehr zufrieden mit.
Preis könnt ihr komplett vergessen.
Ich habe viel weniger bezahlt.
Nachdem mich die eine mit dem Auto über den Haufen gefahren hat,
habe ich noch dieses Fahrrad bekommen.
Da war das letzte Modell in meiner Größe.
Ich habe 2000 irgendeine Biss für bezahlt.
Das ist sehr nice.
also bin ich wirklich sehr zufrieden mit kein dass kein canyon das eine rose kennen heute
wünschen vielleicht kennen wobei die neuen cube dinger finde ich auch gar nicht übel
das ist und was ich ja ursprünglich nur für super spielerei hielte ja ist die elektronische
schaltung ich habe mir einfach alles das gelesen das will ich haben ist mittlerweile muss ich sagen
Ohne Scheiß, elektronische Schaltung ist einfach beste.
Michael, 50 Milliarden, moin.
Also, geschaltet wird natürlich hier die Schaltung.
Unten ist mechanisch.
Aber es gibt nicht mehr wie früher,
dass man quasi vom Lenker so einen Metallfaden durch den Rahmen hat laufen zur Schaltung.
Das geht alles elektronisch mittlerweile hier.
Ein Seilzug, genau.
und ich hatte
ein Fahrrad, wurde umgefahren
und laut Gutachter total schaden.
Da habe ich mir ein neues gekauft.
Also
und was auch mega nice ist, an der
elektronischen Schaltung ist, in
dem, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man
das hier sieht. Man sieht das hier
gar nicht richtig drauf.
In den Huts hier oben
hat das
Man sieht das gar nicht richtig
Ja hier oben sieht man es ein bisschen
Das hat einen Schalter hier oben
Was?
Vielleicht sieht man es doch irgendwie.
Ja doch, hier oben.
Ein bisschen hat man es hier gesehen.
Guck mal.
Hier oben sieht man ein bisschen den Schalter.
Ne, der Schalter ist übrigens hier neben.
Gar nicht hier oben.
Und das hat Schalter hier nebendran.
Und da kannst du dein Fahrradcomputer...
Also das hier oben ist...
Oben oder an der Seite?
Ich bin jetzt gerade echt ein bisschen planlos.
Habe ich die oben oder an der Seite?
Ne, oben habe ich die.
Oben.
Oben, nicht an der Seite.
damit kannst du dein fahrradcomputer steuern du musst quasi die hände nicht vom lenker nehmen
und kannst trotzdem dein fahrradcomputer steuern darüber das ist richtig nice deswegen bin ich
aber so elektronische schaltung mit den spielern beste so jetzt wurde ich aber richtig hart
sidetracked wo war man denn eigentlich stehen geblieben ursprünglich marzett wo waren wir
ursprünglich stehen geblieben.
Nicht beim C++ Flame Video.
Bei TechnoTim.
Okay, wir haben es jetzt in zwei Stunden geschafft,
9 Minuten 24 zu gucken von dem Video.
Ups, falsches.
Super.
Chat, danke für die ganzen Subscriptions heute.
Guck mal, dass ich keinen vergessen habe.
Mario, dich hab ich glaube ich vergessen
Sorry, Dankeschön für den Sub Mario
Ganz vergessen, ich hoffe du bist noch da
Du bist jetzt nicht Ragequitted
Der Ritzkohl auch wieder am Start, auch nicht gesehen
Meine Güte, Dankeschön für den Sub
Totoruns, Dankeschön für den Sub
Auch nicht gesehen, MTR, schlimm hier
Alter, ganzen Subscriptions übersehen
YukiCat auch übersehen
Danke Leute für den Sub.
Alter.
Das habe ich aber vorgelesen.
So, dann gucken wir mal kurz weiter.
Also ganz ehrlich, das PoE-Zeug von dem interessiert mich jetzt nicht so wirklich.
Das sind Fragen, die weder ich noch der Chat hier wahrscheinlich besonders gut beantworten können.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass Linux-Skills da enorm wichtig für sind.
Also ohne Linux-Skills kann ich mir das ja heute nicht vorstellen.
Kannst du hier quasi die AMD Grafikkarte unter Linux einrichten?
Stimmt Arch Linux usen, das ist richtig, eindeutig, ja.
Okay, das interessiert mich nicht hier.
Power Control.
Okay, das finde ich wiederum ganz interessant.
Was sind das eigentlich für komische Stecker? Das sind die Ami-Stecker, oder?
Kona-Stecker.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, CacheOS ist nix, da muss schon Arch from scratch installiert werden.
Also richtig, und auch nicht Arch Installer, sondern so richtig wie man das früher gemacht hat.
Das ist quasi eine überdimensionierte smarte Steckdosenleiste, oder?
Das Ding.
Ich habe hier übrigens noch, habe ich letztens im Schrank gefunden,
ich bin teilweise echt verwirrt, was das angeht.
Ich habe mir so viel Zeug über die Jahre bestellt,
dass ich manchmal gar nicht weiß, dass ich mir was bestellt habe.
Ich habe hier so ein Ding im Schrank gefunden, was eigentlich auf den ersten Blick richtig pock aussieht und angeblich auch ZigBee-Unterstützung hat.
Und zwar ein, pass mal auf, ich gebe das jetzt mal ein, was da hinten drauf steht, SM302EPA20.
So ein Ding hier, guck mal.
Ja, so sieht das aus.
eigentlich von dem
ganz recht cool. Du hast
vier, ich hab's aber bis jetzt
noch nicht zum Laufen gekriegt, weil ich zu dumm bin dafür.
Du hast vier ganz
normale Steckdosen. Du hast
für USB
hast zweimal
Oldschool-USB,
dann USB
Quick Charge, 18 Watt
und hier noch ein
20 Watt USB-C.
Eigentlich eine richtig coole Steckdose. Und angeblich
kann man alles voneinander getrennt schalten.
Also ich glaube die, hier unten
sieht man auf der App, ich glaube die
USB-Stecker nur.
So, der wird
angeblich von ZigBee2MQTT
unterstützt, aber
unter einem anderen Namen.
Unter einem anderen Namen. Ich hab den schon
gefunden unter einem anderen Namen.
Das ist der falsche.
Ja, ich hab den schon gefunden unter einem anderen Namen.
Aber ich krieg's trotzdem nicht gepairt.
Das funzt einfach nicht.
Okay, die Seite lädt nicht.
Ich krieg's einfach nicht gebacken.
das Ding über ZigBee, JMQTT zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Weil das wäre echt für den...
Ich baue mal hier noch einen Schreibtisch hin auf die Seite
zum Basteln. Das wäre eine gute Sache
für den Schreibtisch. Da hat man nämlich
4x USB und 4x
Schuko-Stecker.
Eigentlich ziemlich nice für so ein Bastelding.
Hast du das Ding nicht damals
im Stream geflasht?
Nee, habe ich nicht. Das war was anderes.
Okay, die Seite lädt nicht.
Ja, muss ich mal gucken. Irgendwie zu blöd für gewesen.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal weiter.
Okay, was haben wir denn? Local Camera Storage, juckt mich nicht.
UPS Maintenance, juckt mich auch nicht.
Computer Cluster, Computer Cluster. Okay, was hat er denn da am Start?
Vor allem wie viel Zeug.
Proxmox.
Ah, okay, warte mal, zeig mal her.
Zigbee Model TS011F Zigbee.
Da gibt es doch diese Seite.
Ne.
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Okay, anscheinend
erkennt die das doch direkt.
Na gut, es hat bei mir nicht funktioniert.
Es hat irgendwie, irgendwie war ich da zu blöd für.
Ich hab's nicht zum Laufen gekriegt.
War ich das da?
Ah, das ist die, das ist die Kokona-Variante davon.
Das ist die Kokona-Variante.
Ah, gut.
Wir werden mal gucken, ob ich das irgendwie noch zum Laufen kriege,
weil das wäre für so einen Basteltisch ganz gut.
In a Cluster, I'm not running high availability LXCs or virtual machines, but I do have them in a Cluster.
To give me a single pane of glass...
Äh, hä? Jetzt check ich's nicht.
Warum hat er denn die drei Proxmox-Dinger, wenn er keine VMs und kein LXC drauflaufen lässt?
Oder habe ich das jetzt falsch verstanden?
In a Cluster, I'm not running high availability LXCs or virtual machines, but I do have them in a Cluster.
Ach so, nicht HA.
Ganz ehrlich, die drei VMs, die er da laufen hat mit Software, die nicht nur vom Management des Managements da ist, die könnte er wahrscheinlich auch mit dem Private Open lassen.
und da drüber kubernetes okay ja kann man machen wenn man vor allem und container haben will warum
man sich daheim kubernetes antut ist mir zwar komplett schleierhaft aber gut nix sehe ich
ganz genauso.
Machst du das YouTube-Video posten? Ja, kann ich machen.
Ich finde
HA zu Hause
meistens auch unsinnig.
Also
HA ist High Availability.
Also so Sachen wie zum Beispiel
ein Cluster aus zwei Computern,
wo dann einer
aktiv ist und der eine übernimmt,
sollte der andere kaputt gehen oder sowas.
Ein Cluster mit zwei ist eh schon fragwürdig.
Aber ich finde High Availability
auch daheim fragwürdig.
aus mehreren gründen das erste ist es kostet was und nicht zu wenig wenn du
ein high availability cluster bauen willst brauchst du mindestens drei notes
chat warum drei notes
forum split frame ganz genau ich sehe der chat kennt sich aus exzellent richtig weil überlegt
euch mal ihr habt nur zwei server ja auch für upgrades auch aber überlegt euch mal ihr habt
nur zwei server also machen wir mal machen wir mal jetzt ein bild okay jetzt mal hier okay die
Die coolen Leute heutzutage benutzen doch Excalibur oder...
What the hell?
Excalibur benutzen die Leute doch.
Also, Moment, Moment, Dark Mode.
Ah, Chat, wo ist Dark Mode? Gibt es ein Dark Mode?
Boah, meine Augen, Alter.
Also, stell dir mal vor, ihr habt zwei Computer.
So, hier, zack.
Das ist hier Node 1.
Das ist Node 2.
So, jetzt machen wir mal so ein ganz klassisches
HA-Setup.
Es gibt eine IP, kein Loadbalancer
oder irgendwie sowas, es gibt eine IP.
Es gibt hier
0.69
Okay?
Das ist die IP von meinem
Service.
Service, der von außen angesprochen wird.
Okay?
Wird von außen angesprochen.
So.
Das ist Active Passive.
Und was jetzt passiert ist,
diese Dinger,
hier haben wir noch einen
Switch oder sowas,
wobei das auch schon wieder fragwürdig ist, wir machen es mal direkt.
So.
Die Dinger sind hier miteinander verbunden.
Okay.
Die da, die zwei Kisten.
Schätke, Sekunde.
Okay, also die hier sind per Netzwerk miteinander verbunden, okay?
Die zwei Nodes.
Wir machen das mal ein bisschen auseinander.
Exzellent.
Die zwei Nodes sind netzwerktechnisch miteinander verbunden.
So.
Darauf läuft dann sowas wie...
Wie hieß... Corosync?
War das früher?
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Chat, ihr wisst das doch bestimmt.
War das Corosync für dieses IP-Sharen?
Ich hab das schon ewig nicht mal gemacht von Hand.
Ähm...
Keepalive. Keepalive-D.
Du hast recht. Keepalive-D war das.
So.
also hier gibt es auf beiden notes läuft kippe live dem so hieß das ding erbrecht
genauso und das täuscht sich über das netzwerk aus miteinander
das tauscht sich über das netzwerk miteinander aus sollte jetzt also der
plan ist jetzt sollte dieser note sollte dieser note ausfallen ok dann übernimmt der note diese
ip also wenn der jetzt kaputt ist wenn der jetzt wenn der der date ist dann sollte kieper live das
erkennen und die ip hierüber switchen auf den so dass die services weiter auf dem laufen und
angesprochen werden man sieht jetzt hier schon mehrere probleme das erste ist man braucht zweimal
die gleiche hardware das kostet schon mal ordentlich was es ist ein recht komplexes setup
was auch fehler birgt so und jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten punkt du hast nur zwei nodes und jetzt
gibt es ein problem was machst du denn jetzt wenn die netzwerkverbindung kaputt ist zwischen den zwei
wenn die zwei sich nicht mehr sehen stellt euch das mal vor was passiert dann die netzwerkverbindung
ist kaputt zwischen denen jetzt denkt node 2 weil die netzwerkverbindung weg ist node 2 denkt
Note 1 ist kaputt
und Note 1 denkt,
Note 2 ist kaputt.
Das wird dazu führen, dass du auf einmal
die gleiche IP hast
auf beiden Servern.
Und dann hast du Probleme.
Das heißt, um das richtig zu machen,
bräuchtest du schon einmal
drei Nodes.
Weil dann kannst du sagen,
was sieht die Mehrheit?
Du hast drei Nodes, die miteinander verbunden sind.
korrekt korrekterweise muss man die aber dann so miteinander verbinden
sonst
da habt ihr es nicht richtig ja also man muss das dann muss so miteinander verbunden sein
So.
Und jetzt
hast du den Vorteil, wenn
jetzt das Netzwerk hier dazwischen
wegfällt oder so, kannst du immer noch sagen,
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der sieht den.
Der sieht den, der sieht den, der sieht den.
Die sehen dich ja. Okay, dann
hast du das Problem
nicht mehr.
Oder auch wenn dieser
Node hier komplett wegfällt, ja,
Da können die zwei sagen, ah Moment, Moment, Moment.
Oder wenn der hier jetzt wegfällt, ne?
Wenn der jetzt wegfällt, dann können die sagen, okay, ich sehe, dass der weg ist.
Ich sehe, dass der weg ist.
Wir entscheiden uns jetzt dafür, Node 1 ist down.
Wir müssen die IP übernehmen und dann können die sich untereinander ausmachen, wer die IP kriegt.
Also in diesem Fall ist es deutlich schwieriger, so eine Split-Brain-Geschichte hinzukriegen mit zwei IPs.
So und wenn du es jetzt richtig machen willst, dann darf das hier natürlich auch nicht über den gleichen Switch laufen wie das hier. Das heißt du bräuchtest eine extra Infrastruktur oder extra Netzwerkkarten, um die Kisten miteinander zu verbinden.
Weil würde das alles über den gleichen Switch laufen, sobald der Switch ausfällt,
dann haben wir das gleiche Problem, alle drei denken, die anderen sind weg.
Und wenn du es noch richtiger machen willst und noch besser machen willst,
geht das gar nicht über das Netzwerk, sondern zusätzlich noch ein eigenes Netzwerk
für diese Intercluster-Kommunikation und ein eigenes Storage,
nochmal quasi noch ein zweites Medium, worüber die diesen Austausch machen können.
So und jetzt siehst du das Problem
Das ist schweineteuer
Und es ist komplex
Und durch die Komplexität ist das was der Florian schreibt
Im Chat gerade, ne der Flosian schreibt
Im Chat
Durch diese Komplexität hast du am Ende
Unterm Strich in so einem Heim-Setup
Mehr Ausfälle
Als durch eine Kiste
Und wenn die Kiste kaputt ist
Schaltest du halt aus, wechselst die Festplatte und fährst wieder hoch
Die Komplexität ist nicht zu unterschätzen bei so einem Ding
Also ich hab schon, ich hab schon ohne Scheiß, ich hab mehr Ausfälle erlebt
Durch irgendwelche HA-Konfigurationen, die nicht richtig funktioniert haben
Als durch wirklichen Hardware-Ausfall
Ja, wir hatten beispielsweise mal sowas mit Keeper-Live-D und HA-Proxys
Wie oft da Mist geschwenkt wurde, Alter
Und dann hast du das Problem noch, dass wenn die IP hier umzieht
dann auch erstmal hier richtig schön broadcastet werden muss dass der switch
das mitbekommt und was das ist ein äußerst komplexes setup und auf kuba
nettes cluster kann man es mehr oder weniger übertragen weil kuba net das
cluster die müssen ja irgendwo drauf laufen ja die müssen auch den kuba net
es läuft ja nicht einfach in der luft wir müssen auf vorhersagen die müssen
vielleicht auf auf bär metal sachen laufen aber die müssen ja unter der
haube ist ja nicht cloud wo du sagst ich will einfach ein kuba net das cluster
haben interessiert nicht worauf das läuft du hast du wirklich die hardware
da so und da hast du so ein ding vielleicht einmal proxmox unten drunter
darauf vms noch mit einem kubernetes klasse ganz ehrlich das sieht auf dem
papier super krass nice ausfallsicher und hoch verfügbar aus in der praxis
hast du mehr ausfälle durch sachen die bei high availability skalieren und
sonst was schief gehen können als bei einer kiste mit drei vms mit allem was
du brauchst bei dir daheim und und du hast auch sehr viel maintenance auf
erhält und sowas du musst du einmal drei notes updaten und immer darauf achten
dass du aufpasst videos machst ja nicht dass du auf einmal hier eine falsche
config für dein kippe live hast das passt da nicht mehr zusammen und es ist
wirklich nicht ohne so ein setup
übrigens das ist auch ein bisschen der unterschied zwischen ich kaufe mir den
Managed Kubernetes Cluster bei einem Cloud-Anbieter
versus ich baue das bei Hetzner
beispielsweise selbst.
Wenn du ein Managed Kubernetes Cluster bei einem Cloud-Anbieter
kaufst, bei Google oder sowas, bei Azure,
bei AWS, bei Amazon,
ist ja egal, dann kümmert sich Amazon
da drum.
Du kannst dein Kubernetes-Zeug deployen und gut ist
und je nachdem,
wie gut es der Cloud-Anbieter macht, wirst du nie davon
merken, wenn hier mal eine Node verreckt zwischendurch.
Dann wird ein neuer
Node automatisch aufgebaut,
der Workload wird migriert und nach 2 Minuten
ist wieder alles top.
Das ist Excalibur.
Siehst du doch da. Ja, guck hier.
Excalibur.
Und
wenn du das selbst machst bei Hetzner,
dann musst du dich selbst um die Nodes kümmern.
Und dann auch noch viel mehr dabei.
Ja, weil man könnte ja beispielsweise
auch sagen, okay, unser
Backend besteht als drei Nodes.
Das hier ist aber auf einem
Loadbalancer. Da musst du den Loadbalancer
hochverfügbar machen noch und sowas.
Bei Hetzner glücklicherweise hat er mittlerweile Lautbalancer.
Also es ist nicht so einfach.
Ich glaube man hat verstanden, was ich sagen wollte.
Das macht es komplex.
Bei uns an der Arbeit ist das
zur Zeit der Fall, dass wir wegen HA mehr Probleme
haben als Ausfallsicherheit.
Ja, ja, exakt. Das ist auch so.
Das ist auch so. Also das erfordert
wirklich genaue Planung und
Overhead, dass ein
HA-Setup wirklich mehr HA
ist als eine einzelne Kiste.
das heißt man sollte sich genau überlegen ob es sinn macht an der stelle ja wenn man jetzt sagt
das hier ist netzwerk gerät wo der traffic durchgeht vom ganzen haus und auch fünf minuten
ausfall da sind sind fatal ja dann muss man sich das angucken wie man das macht da gibt
glücklicherweise je nachdem was man dafür hersteller hat ist das da schon eingebaut
Aber selbst wenn man es selbst macht, muss man sich halt genau überlegen.
Aber es macht nicht bei allem Sinn.
Wenn man beispielsweise irgendeine Buchhaltungsanwendung oder so hat,
da muss man sich halt fragen, muss das wirklich High Available sein?
Wenn das mal eine Viertelstunde weg ist, ist das so schlimm?
Cold Standby ist beispielsweise was, was ich persönlich gern habe.
Also Cold Standby ist im Endeffekt, wenn wir das hier haben,
Was ich hier gerade...
Was ich hier gerade gebaut habe.
Cold Standby wäre im Endeffekt...
Du hast quasi...
Den gleich...
Das Gleiche ist den gleichen Server.
Nochmal hier fertig konfiguriert stehen.
Der ist aber nicht...
Der ist aber nicht eingeschaltet.
Der ist nicht eingeschaltet.
So.
Und wenn dieser Node hier verreckt...
Dann schaltest du den Server einfach ein.
Und gut ist.
Ja.
Also Cold Standby finde ich persönlich viel, viel besser als sein Ruf.
Du sparst dir die ganze HA-Komplexität.
Ja, du brauchst extra Hardware, aber je nachdem, vielleicht ist es ja auch notwendig für den Service.
Und in 5 Minuten ist das Ding an.
Und je nachdem, welche Anwendung, ist das vollkommen fein, wenn die mal 5 Minuten weg ist.
Oder eine Viertelstunde oder sowas.
Manche Anwendungen können einen halben Monat weg sein,
keine interessiert's.
Ja, Cold Standby ist nicht beliebt,
du brauchst halt doppelt so viele Kisten.
Aber ich finde, das ist viel besser als sein Ruf.
Tja.
sehr schön deswegen was man übrigens auch sehr gut sieht hier dran vielleicht noch mal kurz
angemerkt was man ja auch sehr gut sieht ist das war jetzt weiß ich euch gezeigt habe das klassische
old school herr set habe hier mit drei cluster notes was man ja auch dann sieht warum virtualisierung
und in neueren zeiten containerisierung so was heißt es ist weil ist es nicht ganz schön kacke
aber mehr kann ich nicht zurück machen. Ist es nicht ganz schön kacke, drei Kisten hier zu haben,
wo nur eine wirklich was macht? Den Link habe ich nicht gesehen. Ist ja ganz schön kacke. So,
mit Virtualisierung, wenn du hier einen VM-Cluster drunter hast, da kannst du die Hardware halt
besser auslasten. Da kannst du dann hier diesen Service drauf laufen lassen, da diesen Service,
da diesen Service und auch die HA-Funktionalität benutzen von deinem jeweiligen Hypervisor,
setup wenn deine not weg fällt und wenn du es mit container hast auch so ja bei kuba net das ist es
so der workload wird verteilt über drei notes fällt ein not weg muss ein dritter not mussten
dritter not wieder aufgebaut werden und der workload wird automatisch wieder verteilt
du kannst deine hardware auch besser auslasten ich bin der chat weiß bescheid
Und das nächste ist...
Das nächste ist, Chat...
Ähm...
Ah, jetzt habe ich...
Bin umgeschaltet.
Was soll denn das sein?
Äh, und...
Und was zum...
Was, wie jetzt, wo jetzt?
Was bringt das?
für den Server.
Und was auch so ein Ding ist,
wo manche Leute ein bisschen ins Klo greifen,
ist Raid.
Eines meiner Lieblingsthemen, wo ich mich immer drüber auslasse.
Raid ist
ein Schutz
vor allem Möglichen.
Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen,
Raid schafft auch extra Komplexität,
die kaputt gehen kann.
Zum Beispiel,
Was total oft unterschätzt wird, ist, wie schnell Platten kaputt gehen können bei einem Rebuild,
beziehungsweise wie schnell es auffällt, dass eine Platte nicht mehr komplett lesbar ist bei einem Rebuild.
Selbst, lassen wir mal Raid-Controller, das ist auch, lassen wir mal Raid-Controller außen vor, ja,
wir machen, keine Ahnung, MD-Raid unter Linux, ja, oder wir machen mit ZFS, wir machen mit ZFS-Raid,
ZFS RAID 1 oder irgendwie sowas, was
quasi RAID 5 ist.
RAID 5, sagen wir, wir machen
RAID 5. Bisher ist es aber egal, mit was wir RAID 5
machen. RAID 5 ist was,
das mögen viele Leute,
weil RAID 5, das ist im Prinzip
eigentlich genauso, was die KI hier sagt,
RAID 5 sieht erstmal nach einer guten
Mischung aus zwischen Kosten
und Kapazität. Also sprich,
bei RAID 5, ja, RAID 5 wird
beispielsweise gerne mit drei Platten gemacht,
ja, bei RAID 5 ist es so,
du kaufst dir drei Platten,
du kannst die Kapazität von zwei
verwenden und einen
Ausfall abfangen. Soweit in der
Theorie, ja.
Das Problem ist jetzt allerdings nur,
warte mal hier, Rate,
Error Calculator.
Gibt es hier einen
schönen Calculator? Da muss man aufpassen,
das ist nicht mehr so ganz aktuell.
Ich glaube, es ist eher 10.15 Uhr oder so
mittlerweile bei aktuellen Platten.
Müsste man mal schauen, aber
Nur mal als Beispiel.
Ihr habt einen RAID 5.
Jetzt habt ihr hier drei
Platten.
Drei Platten, RAID 5
ist kein Ding.
Wir müssen das doch eins hochschalten,
das ist sonst zu unrealistisch.
Drei Platten, RAID 5
sollte eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Also 4 Terabyte.
Mit größeren Platten gibt es übrigens
mehr Probleme. Also ganz
klar, ich sage, ihr habt 4 Terabyte Platten,
RAID 5,
Ihr müsst, auf das hier kommt es an, ne?
Da muss man in den Datenplatten bei den Festplatten gucken.
Was denn hier?
Die Unrecoverable Error Rate.
Gucken wir doch mal aktuell hier.
Seagate, Iron Wolf, äh, weiß nicht, 12 Terabyte.
Data Sheet.
Und dann machen wir mal was anderes.
Komm, nehmen wir mal so eine neue.
So eine 28 Terabyte.
Pro.
Pro, das sind die.
Die sollten wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen...
Nach was muss ich ihn da suchen, Leute?
Error-Rate?
Hier, 15. Hier, 10.15 Uhr.
10.15 Uhr, okay?
28T. Kann man hier gar nicht machen.
Gehen wir einfach mal von aus.
So, und jetzt machen wir mal einen Rate 5
mit 6 Platten. Guckt mal da.
Leute.
Oder machen wir einen Rate 5 mit, keine Ahnung, 4 Platten
oder 5 Platten haben wir auch noch.
Das hat nur
68% Chance, dass der
Rebuild ordentlich funktioniert.
weil RAID 5 funktioniert ja
über XOR.
Das heißt, wenn was geschrieben wird,
oder wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten?
Also wenn Daten auf die Platte geschrieben werden,
dann wird das quasi auf Platte 1 geschrieben,
auf Platte 2 geschrieben,
dann werden die Sachen XOR miteinander
und das, was als Ergebnis rauskommt,
wird auf die dritte Platte geschrieben.
Chat, stimmt das, was ich erzähle?
Schon lange keine Gedanken mehr drüber gemacht,
aber ich glaube, das stimmt.
ich hoffe das ist so bei raid 5 so und dementsprechend kannst du immer wenn du
die daten von einer platte plus die parität daten von der zweiten platte noch lesbar ist
die andere platte recover also parität starten werden auf alle drei platten gleichermaßen
geschrieben und es reicht wenn du eine platte plus die parität starten von der anderen platte
da kannst du nämlich wieder zurück x-ohren
lesen kannst
und dann kannst du die die ausgefallene platte recovern so funktioniert das irgendwie bei raid 5. Ich bin bei 100%
ich krieg's aus dem kopf auch nicht mehr zusammen. So du hast jetzt allerdings ein problem
wenn du das raid
rebuilden willst also sprich eine platte fällt aus dann müssen die anderen platten
100% in ordnung sein
weil du musst ja quasi sektor für sektor dort
lesen parity lesen x-ohren und wenn da irgendwas nicht richtig lesbar ist dann hast du fehler im
rebuild im schlimmsten fall ist dann im arsch also raid 5 ist viel fehleranfälliger als man so denkt
wie sieht das mit erweitern aus eine platte dazu das geht prinzipiell bei raid 5 da musste das wie
weiß nicht wie man das nennt wie silvan heißt parzell fs das geht theoretisch ja
also ich glaube man kann ich bin mir da geil md md md xtent das geht irgendwie
ja neue platte vorbereiten das geht man kann das irgendwie exzellenz die chance
auf fails das geht extrem hoch je nach platte kuppa sagt zack zack zack
ansplatten bei 20 platten hast du nur 16 prozent chance dass überhaupt klappt
Aber selbst bei so einem Standardding, ja, guckt mal hier, 12 Terabyte, äh, 12 Terabyte Platten und nur drei Stück, du hast nur 83% Chance, dass das succeedet.
Würdet ihr, würdet ihr mit einem Fahrstuhl fahren, wo ihr 17% Chance habt abzustürzen?
So, ich nett.
YOLO, vielleicht manche, keine Ahnung.
Ist bei einem Read Error dann der ganze Rebuild kaputt oder nur der Sektor oder was auch immer?
Also ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Ich würde sagen, der Sektor ist kaputt.
Die Frage, ob der kaputte Sektor Auswirkungen hat, hängt ein bisschen von den Daten und dem Filesystem ab, die drauf sind.
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob dabei in dem ersten error direkt aussteigt beim
rebuild was md md linux md rater machen würde aber selbst wenn nicht selbst wenn
ich gehe mal davon aus der rebuild würde nicht abbrechen
das ist genau das gleiche wenn du zfs mit parity mit einem per mit einer party des da machst das
ist gehen wir mal von aus der raid würde nicht abbrechen dann hast du schlicht ergreifend
verlorene kaputte sektoren so das kann ein fall system kaputt machen das kann eine daten kaputt
machen es kann auch ein sektor sein der tag komplett unwichtig ist kommt wahrscheinlich
einfach darauf an welcher sektor das war das ist dann so ein bisschen russisch roulette ja wenn du
pech hast was sektor von einem bootloader gestartet die kiste nicht mehr oder aber es
war ein sektor innerhalb von der engrifteten datei und ist dann komplett nicht mehr lesbar
aber ich würde mal behaupten im krankenhaus ist das ganze dann doch ein bisschen besser
als drei nachts prozent so bei standard sachen also also hätte ich die chance bei einem blind
zu 17% nicht mal nach Hause zu kommen,
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich den Blindarm nicht rausmachen lassen.
Na doch, muss ich ja. Ich meine, wenn er
entzündet ist. An manchen Sachen würde ich dann eher
nicht machen, bei 17% Chance abzukratzen.
Wie war das nochmal? Ist die Parity nicht? Doch, die Parity
ist verteilt bei Raid 5.
Bei Raid 5 werden die Daten
einmal geschrieben, zweimal geschrieben.
Ähm, Parity.
Und...
Och, keine Ahnung. Ich krieg's... Doch, doch, die Parity
wird verteilt.
Die Parody von der einen
auf Disk...
Ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen.
Hier, XOR RAID 5.
Parody ist auf jeden Fall auf jeder Disk drauf.
Deswegen kann jede Platte ausfallen.
Ja, guck hier genau.
Der macht hier das hier, XOR C3.
Es ist auf jeden Fall über alle Platten verteilt.
Wo sind eigentlich die ganzen
fieses die das gelernt haben müssen bei mir ist das so lange her ich kann das schon wieder
vergessen haben eine fieses diese abschlussprüfung hatten nach der prüfung vergessen ja ich auch aber
man sieht es geht ganz schön schnell kaputt deswegen wenn raid wenn man was wenn man den
raid 5 macht oder wenn man ein raid machen will mit mehr als drei platten sagen wir mal zum
beispiel möchte es mit vier platten machen dann ist nur sechs gut ja red 6
ist immer super dafür die allerdings mit fünf machen red 6 ist zwei platten
können ausfallen das finde ich schon ganz gut und was ich was ich persönlich
auch ganz gut finde ist 1 0 das ist nicht ganz so ausfallsicher hat aber
ordentlich speed wuns und ich persönlich ja ich mache weder red 5 noch
Raid 6, noch Raid 1.0.
Auch wenn ich Raid 1.0 ganz nice finde.
Ich mach Raid 1.
Ich bin super krasser Kack-Noob.
Ich mach ein Raid 1.
Und im Zweifelsfall,
also wenn ich überhaupt ein Raid mache,
mach ich ein Raid 1.
Und noch eine dritte
Platte für
Airsoom einmal nachts.
Und aktuell ist es sogar so,
wenn ich die neue
Nasskiste baue, wahrscheinlich,
nachdem ja meine ganzen
VMs und Sachen eh auf nem
RAID 1 mit SSD liegen
werde ich einfach nen Backup nachts machen
auf ne Platte, die da drin hängt
und den dann nochmal eher so auf ne zweite
Platte, das heißt ich mach im Endeffekt gar keinen
Platten-Mirror mehr
oder vielleicht doch, ich weiß es noch nicht genau
RAID 1
RAID 1 ist super
und mit der Kapazität
die man mittlerweile bekommt bei Festplatten
leider nicht mehr erschwinglich, weil
es alles sau teuer geworden ist.
Geht das auch gut, ja?
Was gab's?
Ups.
Ne, Unraid ist wieder ein bisschen...
Unraid sieht schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Ich glaube, in Unraid,
die machen das eh anders. Die machen das ja, glaube ich,
irgendwie
offline, die machen quasi nicht während
dem Schreiben Parity, die machen quasi
einmal nachts Parity Daten
und du kannst bei Unraid ja glaube ich auch verschiedene
große Plattformen, das ist nochmal ein bisschen anders.
Bei Unraid verlierst du ja dann
auch nicht die kompletten Daten, sondern nur
die Daten, die auf einer Platte drauf waren.
Deswegen hast du bei Unraid aber auch keinen
Geschwindigkeitsboost von einem Raid.
Außer beim Lesen, glaube ich, beim Lesen schon.
So.
Chat, ich hab ein Problem.
Ich muss jetzt Mittag essen.
Wir sind schon 4 Stunden 20 am Start.
Ich hab heute, das war heute wirklich, glaube ich, die schlechteste Ausbeute von Videos, die wir geguckt haben.
14 Minuten Video geguckt, vorher 2 Stunden gelabert und dann wieder 2 Stunden gelabert.
Das war jetzt nicht so dolle.
aber so ist es chat sorry falls ich irgendwas im chat überlesen habe was ich nicht beantwortet habe
ich habe nicht alles gesehen heute ihr könnt ja an der stelle einfach von unter sei das nächste
mal wieder mit dabei und ich werde das nächste mal beantworten wenn ihr wieder am start sein
könnte es einfach wieder ein chat posten und dann machen wir das kommst du wieder ich würde
euch sicher ob ich heute mittag da bin es könnte es wird mal wieder zeit für stellenanzeigen oder
Oder? Glaube ich, Chat. Was sagt ihr?
Stellenanzeigen angucken zusammen.
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir das heute Mittag.
Okay, wir sehen uns, Leute. Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.